COULD AND WELCOME THIS IS THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER ONE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND TODAY'S HEARING
WILL COVER THE HUMAN SERVICES
RELATED PROPOSALS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION. SUB ONE
HEARD THE HEALTH RELATED
PROPOSALS IN YESTERDAY'S HEARING
THANKS TO THOSE WHO ARE ABLE TO
JOIN US. PURSUANT TO OUR USUAL
PROTOCOL I WILL READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S HEARING
TO HELP INSURE THE SAFETY OF
EVERYONE HERE TODAY WHILE ALSO
ALLOWING FOR FULL PUBLIC ACCESS
TO THE DISCUSSION. TODAY'S
HEARING IS IN ROOM FOUR FOUR
SEVEN OF THE STATE CAPITOL MOST
OF THE PANELISTS WILL BE
TESTIFYING IN PERSON WHILE
OTHERS WILL BE JOINING US
REMOTELY. WITH WEBEX. WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THE HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET.
THE NUMBER IS TOLL FREE. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE EIGHT
FIVE ZERO ELEVEN HUNDRED. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. WE WILL BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER ALL MEMBERS HAVE
CONCLUDED THEIR QUESTIONS FOR
THE SPEAKER. WE WILL ALSO BE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND FEEDBACK THROUGH
THE SUB ONE EMAIL ACCOUNT AND
THE ADDRESS IS BUDGET SUB ONE AT
ASM DOT CA DOT GOV. TODAY WE
PLAN TO TAKE VOTES ON. TO
APPROVE ACTIONS THERE ARE TO
VOTE ONLY AGENDAS ONE FOR THE
HEALTH ISSUES POSTPONED FROM
YESTERDAY'S HEARING. AND ONE FOR
THE HUMAN SERVICES ISSUES. MOST
OF THESE ACTIONS ARE PERTAINING
TO THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY AND
APRIL PROPOSAL AND THEY ARE NOT.
ON THE MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
WHICH WE WILL CONTINUE TO LEARN
ABOUT TODAY. WE WILL ADDRESS
THESE VOTES AS SOON AS WE CAN
THIS AFTERNOON AND AS WE HAVE A
QUORUM I WOULD ASK FOR US TO
ESTABLISH. DR AMBULANCE. HERE
MISTER MATHAS HERE MR PATTERSON
MISTER AHMOSE. THIS RUBIO DOCTOR
WOULD FOREIGN NOW THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED QUORUM LET'S BEGIN
WITH VOTES FOR THE TO VOTE ONLY
AGENDAS WE'LL START WITH THE
HELP VOTE ONLY AGENDA. WE ARE
BEGINNING WITH THE AGENDA THAT
INCLUDES THE EIGHTY FOUR JANUARY
AND APRIL HEALTH PROPOSALS FROM
THE GOVERNOR. FIRST CAN I PLEASE
HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS ITEMS ONE
THROUGH ELEVEN ITEMS THIRTEEN
ITEMS FIFTEEN THROUGH TWENTY ONE
ITEMS TWENTY THREE THROUGH FIFTY
EIGHT. ITEMS. SIXTY THREE SIXTY
THREE AND ITEM SIXTY FIVE TO
EIGHTY FOUR HELLO. CAN WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA I MATHIS
PATTERSON RAMOS RUBIO I WOULD
THINK. NEXT CAN I PLEASE HAVE A
MOTION TO APPROVE EXCUSE ME WE
JUST HAD PATTERSON WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY. GEN
WELL I. DO WANNA. TO THE FIRST
VISIT OF A VOTE ON THE DETAILS
ONE YEAH I'M HERE TO VOTE OKAY
TO WITHIN AN INCH OF ICE YEAH.
TO HELP THE YOUNG IS. AB
PATTERSON. FROM THE EYES TWO
NEXT CAN I PLEASE HAVE A MOTION
TO APPROVE STAFF FOR THE FOLLOW
ITEMS ITEM TWELVE FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO AND FIFTY NINE. MOST
OF. CAN WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ARAMBULA I MATHIS. PATTERSON
RAMOS RUBIO WOULD BUY TEAM WE
WILL HOLD THAT OPEN FINALLY CAN
I PLEASE HAVE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
FOR ITEM NUMBER SIXTY FOUR. SO
CAN WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I
MATHIS. PATTERSON RAMOS RUBIO
WOULD CHANGED. UNDERSTANDING
THAT WILL COMPLETE OUR VOTE ONLY
FOR THE HEALTH AGENDA
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE ARE NO
REQUEST FOR MEMBERS TO SEPARATE
VOTES FOR THIS ACTION AGENDA
AGAIN THE HUMAN SERVICES VOTE
ONLY AGENDA THAT IS POSTED ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WE WILL
TAKE UP THE AGENDAS
RECOMMENDATION AS A GROUP IN ONE
VOTE CAN I ASK TO APPROVE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ITEMS
ONE THROUGH FIFTY FIVE INCLUSIVE
OF THIS AGENDA CAN WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA HI
MATHIS- PATTERSON RAMOS. RUBIO
WOULD TANG. ALIVE WE WILL HOLD
THESE ITEMS OPEN NOW WE WILL
MOVE ON TO HEAR THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISION PROPOSALS FOR HUMAN
SERVICES. I DO WANNA UPDATE IF I
CAN THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE WHICH
I MENTIONED EARLIER HAS BEEN
UPDATED AND AGAIN SHOULD BE ON
THE WEBSITE THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR SEVEN. AT THIS TIME AND
WILL PROVIDE A FEW OPENING
COMMENTS BEFORE WE BEGIN. AS
WITH YESTERDAY'S HEARING I'D
LIKE TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY PRIORITY GOALS
REGARDING THE HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS. WE'VE WORKED
COLLECTIVELY EXTREMELY HARD AS
THE STATE TO RESTORE INVESTED IN
AND ELEVATE OUR HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS WHICH SERVE INDIVIDUALS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
FAMILIES WHO ARE LIVING IN DEEP
POVERTY CHILDREN WHO ARE IN OUR
FOSTER CARE PROGRAM. AND THE
AGING POPULATION WITHIN OUR
STATE AMONG OTHER VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. TAKING THE PERSON
CENTERED AND EQUITY ANCHORED
APPROACHES TO HEART WE WANT TO
FOCUS ON AND IMPROVE THE CORE
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS LIKE CAL
WORKS CALIFORNIA FOOD BANKS THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE EFFORT SS I SS
P. I. HSS AND THE REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICES AMONG SO MANY
OTHERS. THESE PROGRAMS NEED TO
BE FULLY ABLE TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE PEOPLE WHO THEY SERVE AND
TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY MAY BE
HAMPERED I BELIEVE IT'S A
BUDGETING PRIORITY TO PROVIDE
THE RESOURCES TO ENSURE THEIR
BASIC FUNCTIONALITY AT WORST AND
THEIR EXCELLENCE AT BEST. WHILE
I'M HEARTENED BY THE MANY
INVESTMENTS WHICH WERE PROPOSED
IN THE MAY REVISION WE ALSO WANT
TO ENSURE THAT OUR CORE PROGRAMS
HAVE WHAT THEY NEED. TO BE
FUNCTIONAL AND O SERVE
COMMUNITIES WELL DURING THIS
FRAGILE TIME. THIS IS A
SENSITIVE MOMENT IN THE PANDEMIC
THROUGH THE INFLATIONARY WAVES
OF THE ECONOMY AND INTO A FUTURE
THAT. HOLDS AN ADDITIONAL
PREMIUM GIVEN THE TERRIBLE
EVENTS OF LATE ON THE VALUES
THAT WE HAVE TOWARDS SAFETY
DECENCY AND THE PEACE WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE'VE COME A LONG
WAY IN OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
HUMAN SERVICES WE KNOW MORE
ABOUT RACIAL DISPARITIES AND
ABOUT THE NEUROTOXICITY OF
POVERTY AND THE INTERVENTIONS
THAT CAN BATTLE THESE CONDITIONS
. IT IS VITAL AT THIS TIME THAT
WE TAKE ACTION TO ENSURE
EQUALITY AND OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
PEOPLE. I AM VERY OPTIMISTIC
THAT WILL COME TO A PRODUCTIVE
AND MEANINGFUL MEETINGS OF THE
MINDS WITH THE BUDGETING
DECISIONS AHEAD I LOOK FORWARD
TO LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE MAY
REVISION ASK SOME KEY QUESTIONS
AND TO HEAR THE INPUT FROM THE
PUBLIC- WE COLLECTIVELY SERVE.
THE BUDGET ACT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BELONGS TO THEM AND I
WANT TO LEARN HOW THEY REACT TO
WHAT THEY'VE BEEN HEARING SEEING
AND LEARNING ABOUT. WITH THAT I
WANT TO ASK MY COLLEAGUES IF
THEY WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ANY
OPENING REMARKS BEFORE WE BEGIN
. SEEING NONE LET'S BEGIN WE
WILL HOLD ALL QUESTIONS UNTIL
AFTER ALL OF THE MAJOR REVISION
PRESENTATIONS PLEASE. I WELCOME
THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES TO
SPEAK TO THE MATE REVISED
PROPOSAL PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU
ARE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN GOOD AFTERNOON-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KENDALL ROSA I AM THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH THE STATE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. I'LL READ FROM
SOME PREPARED REMARKS THAT
BRIEFLY WE HAVE- THREE ITEMS IN
OUR MAY REVISION PROPOSAL. THE
VISION INCLUDES A ONE TIME
INCREASE OF NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDING
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FOR THE
COUNCIL. TO RECRUIT HIRE AND
TRAIN THE PUBLIC HEALTH WORKER
TO RESPOND TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND PREPARE
FOR FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
CHALLENGES. THE REQUESTED A LOT
OF THE COUNCIL TO EXPEND THE
GRANT PROVIDED BY THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION FOR COMMUNITY
LIVING WHICH WAS AWARDED TO US
ON MARCH FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AT THE PROPOSAL A RELATIVE
TO THE NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR GRANT ALSO INCLUDE SOME
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE. TO MAKE
THE GRANT FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR
ENCUMBRANCE THROUGH- JUNE
THIRTIETHOF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
THIS PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY FOR
THE COUNCIL TO EXPEND THE FUNDS
IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
AVAILABILITY OF THOSE FUNDS
UNDER THE- GRANT AWARD.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE INCLUDING A
ONE TIME INCREASE OF
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IT WILL ENABLE THE
COUNCIL TO EXPEND A GRANT
RECEIVED BY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION. THIS GRANT
IS FOR THE PURCHASE AND
DISTRIBUTION OF EMERGENCY GO
KITS- THE CONTINUE READING OF
ITEMS THAT ARE USEFUL FOR PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL OR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. WHO
WILL HAVE TO WHO WOULD HAVE TO
EVACUATE IN THE EVENT OF A
NATURAL DISASTER- THE LAST ITEM.
IS A REAPPROPRIATION OF FEDERAL
FUNDS FROM A VACCINE ACCESS
GRANT THAT WASAWARDED TO THE
COUNCIL LAST YEAR. BY THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION-
COMMUNITY LIVING AND THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL- TO ALLOW
THE COUNTY THE COUNCIL TO FULLY
EXPAND THESE FUNDS WITHIN THE
GRANT PERIOD. THE PURPOSE OF THE
FUNDS IS ALSO RELATED TO CODE
AND IS MEANT TO ASSIST-
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. IN BRINGING
MEMBERS OF THE I. D. D.
COMMUNITY- TO EVENTS OR TO
PROVIDE OUR REGION EDUCATION ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF COVERT
NINETEEN VACCINATIONS. CONCLUDES
MY COMMENTS AVAIL TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE ME
. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
COMMENTS UNTIL BAKER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME BUT ARE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
HELLO A GOOD AFTERNOON SENATE
HEADACHE WITH THE L. A. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU NEXT COULD
WE HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING
SPEAKERS FOR THE CDA ME REVISED
PROPOSALS.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M SUSAN TO MORRIS
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING I AM PLEASED
TO BE HERE TODAY TO HIGHLIGHT
FURTHER INVESTMENTS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE THAT ALLOW
OUR DEPARTMENT TO ADVANCE THE
STATE'S MASTER PLAN FOR AGING.
WE APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE AS TOGETHER WE
ACTIVELY PREPARE FOR THE YEAR
TWENTY THIRTY WHEN ONE IN FOR
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE AGE SIXTY
OR ABOUT. IN JUST OUR SECOND
YEAR OF THE TEN YEAR MASTER PLAN
BLUEPRINT WE ARE STILL BUILDING
LOCAL CAPACITY AND STATEWIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE GOAL IS TO
STRENGTHEN OUR NETWORK TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF A GROWING
POPULATION THAT IS INCREASINGLY
DIVERSE WITH COMPLEX HEALTH AND
SOCIAL NEEDS. WE'LL BE HEARING
ABOUT THE THREE- ITEMS FROM
THOMAS CAMERON HIS JOINING US-
BY PHONE BUT I WANTED TO JUST
HIGHLIGHT THREE- THEMES ONE THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS IN THE MAY
REVISED REFLECT EXEMPLARY CROSS
DEPARTMENT COLLABORATION. AS
YOU'LL SEE WITH THE COULD HOME
AND COMMUNITY BASED
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN AND THE
COMMUNITY LIVING FUND WE'RE
PROUD TO BREAK DOWN SILOS FOR
THE BENEFIT OF OLDER ADULTS
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
FAMILY CAREGIVERS. WE ARE
ELEVATING THE ROLE AND
IMPORTANCE OF FAMILY CAREGIVERS
THE BACKBONE OF OUR LONG TERM
CARE SYSTEM. JUST AS WE INVEST
IN OUR ESSENTIAL DIRECT CARE
WORKFORCE SO TOO MUST WE INVEST
IN UNPAID FAMILY CAREGIVERS. AND
FINALLY WE ARE INVESTING IN
TRAINING OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS INCLUDING THE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN AND OTHERS
WHO HAVE ENDURED THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC AND WHO REMAIN ON THE
FRONTLINES OF OUR COMMUNITIES
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH OLDER
ADULTS PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND FAMILY CAREGIVERS. THANK YOU
AND I BELIEVE THOMAS CAMERON
ARE. DEPUTY DIRECTOR JOINS US
NOW BY PHONE. HELLO MEMBERS AND
SHARED THIS IS THOMAS CAMERON A
DEPUTY DIRECTOR HERE TO
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT BEACHING
AS DIRECTOR MORRIS MENTIONED ALL
WALKERS BRIEFLY THROUGH OUR ME
REVISION PROPOSALS STARTING
GREAT VERY ITS MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING INVESTMENTS- THE
DEPARTMENT HAS REQUESTED AND HE
INVESTMENTS TOTALING EIGHT
POINT. NINE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND THAT IS A
COMBINATION OF BOTH ALL ONE TIME
AND ONGOING RESOURCES FOR THE
FOLLOWING ACTIVITIES. FIRST WE
REQUEST RESOURCES TOTALING FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR THE
H. CBS INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT INITIATIVE. AT
THIS IS TO DEVELOP A STATEWIDE
EACH CBS ROAD SIR WE MAY ASK YOU
TO SPEAK MORE DIRECTLY IN TO THE. MICROPHONE IF POSSIBLE. IS
THAT BETTER. MUCH IMPROVED THANK
YOU- I GET FIRST INVESTMENT IN
THE DBF IN PLANNING AND THE AND
ISSUE AND NOT FORM DOLLAR ONE
JOB FUND TO DEVELOP A STATE EACH
CBS ROAD MAP IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE H. YES WHICH INCLUDES BOTH
MEDICARE AND NON MEDICARE HEALTH
FUNDED EACH TVS FOR OLDER ADULTS
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
CAREGIVERS. STEP WE REQUEST
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
WANT GENERAL FUND. SUPPORT
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN TO RAISE
AWARENESS OF THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO RESIDENTS AND
FAMILIES AND LICENSE LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES THIRTY WITH OUR
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM
. ADDITIONALLY WE REQUEST SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND
A THOUSAND DOLLARS. I'M GOING
AND I PETITIONS TO ESTABLISH A
NEW AGING AND DISABILITY
INSTITUTE OF LEARNING AND
INNOVATION. A COURT LOCAL
NETWORKS AND LEADERS PUBLIC
COMMUNITY CARE PROVIDERS
VOLUNTEERS AND THE LOCAL LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN BY
DEVELOPING AN IMPROVING TRAINING
CONTENT TO FURTHER QUALITY
EFFICIENT. COULDN'T ACCESS TO
SERVICES FOR OLDER ADULTS. LAST
WEEK WE ALSO REQUEST FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWO
POSITIONS ONGOING FOR THE
PREPARE NETWORK SPOTS TO DEVELOP
STRATEGIES. TO RESORT TO HELP
OLDER ADULTS AND INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES CARE GIVERS AT
LOCAL PARTNERS AIRPORT AND
RESPOND TO EMERGING. THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO REQUEST THE
TRANSFER OF FOURTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING AS WELL
AS OVERSIGHT FOR THE CAREGIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS- THAT WOULD
SHIFT FUNDING AND OVERSIGHT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. TO CDMA AND
ADDITIONALLY PROPOSES FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS I'M GOING FOR STATEWIDE
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. ALSO THE DEPARTMENT
REQUEST HAD NOT YET DOLLARS
ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR THE AIR
PORT SUPPORTER PROGRAM. TO HELP
. UNDERSTAND CONSIDER AND
COMMUNICATE DECISIONS BY
PROVIDING THE TOOLS TO MAKE SELF
DIRECTED CHOICES TO THE GREATEST
EXTENT POSSIBLE- LASTLY WE HAVE
TO TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET THE FIRST
ONE BEING A TRANSFER OF LOCAL
ASSISTANCE EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY. FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR OUR
MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM TO ASSIST WITH
ADMINISTRATIVE AND OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES- AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE A REQUEST TO TRANSFER ONE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS OF
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FROM THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
QUALITY. AND ACCOUNTABILITY
SPECIAL FUNDS TO THE GENERAL
FUND. FOR LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM. THANK YOU AND
I HAVE TO HAVE ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
COMMENTS. HELLO COMMITTEE BURMA
FINANCE NO COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
BUT ANSWERING QUESTIONS THANK
YOU HELLO IN THE COMMENTS JACKIE
BRISTOW WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE AS WAS MENTIONED
IN THE OVERVIEW PRIDE BY
DEPARTMENT OF AGING ONE OF THE
PROPOSALS INCLUDED AND THAT THE
BUDGET AND THE MAY REVISE IS TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
pDEPARTMENT OF AGING TO
ADMINISTER THE CARE SUPPORTER
PROGRAM. WHICH IS ONE OF THE
FLAG A FEW THINGS ONE OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THIS IS JUST
ONE OF THREE PROPOSALS THAT MAKE
UP THE ENTIRE CARE COURT PACKAGE
SO IN TOTAL- IT WITH THOSE THREE
PROPOSALS COMBINED THE ACTUAL
COST FOR THE CARE COURT-
PROPOSAL IS SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. ANOTHER THING THAT WE
WOULD FLAG IS THAT. THE FUNDING
BEING REQUESTED THROUGH THE MAY
REVISION- IS TO SUPPORT. A
POLICY BILL CURRENTLY MAKING ITS
WAY THROUGH THE PROCESS- AND
THAT KIND OF LEADS INTO JUST
SOME KEY EXAMPLES OF QUESTIONS-
OUR OFFICE- HAS REGARDING THE
BROADER CARE COURT PROPOSAL ONE
IS GETTING A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF. WHAT ACTUAL
COSTS- I'M IN FUNDING NEEDS
WOULD BE FOR THE CARE COURT
PROGRAM GIVEN THAT ON THE POLICY
IS STILL MAKING ITS WAY THROUGH
THE POLICY PROCESS- UNCLEAR IF
ASPECTS. WOULD CHANGE. ANOTHER
QUESTION THAT WE HAVE- RELATES
TO THE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE VARIOUS
ENTITIES THAT WOULD- BE A PART
OF THE CARE COURT PROCESS FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING. WE KNOW THAT THEIR
EXPERTISE IS REALLY SERVING
OLDER ADULTS AND ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES BAKER CORP
POPULATION- OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
MAY PRESENT UNIQUE- NEEDS THAT
ARE VERY DIFFERENT AND DISTINCT
FROM- THE- OLDER ADULTS ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES ARE GETTING A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF.
UNNECESSARY RESOURCES AND
TRAINING AND TIME IT WOULD TAKE
FOR DEPARTMENT OF AGING TO
DEVELOP THAT EXPERTISE IF THEY
DO TAKE ON THE SUPPORTER
PROGRAM- OTHER QUESTIONS ALSO
INCLUDE. AN BY GETTING A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF. WHETHER THE
CARE PART PROGRAM ALSO PLACE
ADDITIONAL- DEMAND ON EXISTING
STATE AND LOCAL PROGRAMS THAT
COULD BE USED TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES SUCH AS
HOUSING. TO GETTING A BETTER
STANDING UP HOW EXISTING-
RESOURCES WOULD PLUG INTO THE
CAR COURT- PROCESS. ALTOGETHER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YEAH ENDED
UP IN A FROM FINANCE- JUST WOULD
NOT GIVEN. THAT THIS IS
ADMINISTRATION SPONSORED
LEGISLATION FOR THE CARE COURT-
THE MAY REVISION DOES INCLUDE
RESOURCES FOR TO STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND ALSO THAT. THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH- AND WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR AND WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO THE
EXTENT ANY- THAT'S BEEN CHANGES
ARE NECESSARY NEEDED. THANK YOU
WITH THE NEXT COULD WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES SPEAKERS FOR THE DDS
MAY REVISED PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HER LOOK
AS THE OTHER CHIEF DEPUTY RECTOR
FOR DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES OF THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES TWELVE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
OPERATIONS AND THE- SUPPORT OF
THE COMMUNITY PROGRAM- THIS
SUPPORTS THE PROJECTED TO
FLOODING UTILIZATION FOR
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS- IN
ADDITION TO SUPPORTING HISTORY
REALIZATION A NUMBER OF POLICY
JUDGMENTS ARE INCLUDED IN THE
MAY REVISION. THE FIRST OF THESE
NOTED IN THE LETTER IS THE WORK
FOR STABILITY PROPOSAL. THIS
INCLUDES FOUR COMPONENTS- TO
ADDRESS THE CURRENT AND EMERGING
NEED OF THE WORK FORCE-
RECOGNIZING APPROXIMATELY
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY THOUSAND.
ADDITIONAL CONSUMERS PER YEAR
WERE ANTICIPATING A PROJECTED
NEED FOR DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS AS WELL AS SERVICE
COORDINATORS AT REGIONAL
CENTERS. SO THE FOUR COMPONENTS
INCLUDE A TRAINING STIPEND FOR
THE DIRECT SERVICE PROFESSIONALS
SO THIS COULD BE FOR THE NEW AS
WELL AS- EXISTING. THE NEXT ITEM
IS FOR AN INTERNSHIP PROGRAM
THAT WOULD BE TO INCLUDE A NEW
AND DIRECT SERVICE PROFESSIONALS
. AND THEN TO ADDRESS SOME
REGIONAL CENTER SUPPORT
OPERATIONS AS REIMBURSEMENT
PROGRAM FOR UP ARE THE BACHELOR
OR MASTER'S DEGREES. AND THEN
THE LAST COMPONENT IS ALSO
RECOGNIZING THE DESIRE OF
CONSUMERS SOME REALLY WISH TO
HAVE MORE INDEPENDENCE AND
CONSUMER CHOICE. THIS WOULD BE A
PILOT PER PART PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT TECHNOLOGY OPTIONS. THE
NEXT ITEM IN THE MAYOR VISION.
IS OUR SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY
GRANTS SO RECOGNIZING THAT THERE
IS STILL AN EVALUATION UNDERWAY
OF THE CURRENT PROPOSALS OF THE
CURRENT GRANT PROGRAM. I'M
LOKING FOR A ONE YEAR
ADDITIONAL OF ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE- THIS WOULD ALSO INCLUDE
SOME SUPPORT FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH- THE
GRANTEES. THE NEXT ITEM IS OUR
EARLY START ELIGIBILITY. AND
WE'RE PROPOSING TO CHANGE THE
REDUCE THE THRESHOLD FOR
ELIGIBILITY FROM 33% TO TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT- THIS IS KIND OF IN
LINE WITH A NUMBER OF OTHER
STATES ALREADY. WE'RE ALSO
PROPOSING TO CHANGE ELIGIBILITY
M. SEPARATE THE COMMUNICATION
ASSESSMENT SO BREAKING OUT
RECEPTIVE AND EXPRESSIVE
LANGUAGE COMMUNICATION. AND THEN
HIGHLIGHTING THE THAT THE FETAL
ALCOHOL SYNDROME AND THE RISKS
THAT THAT MAY POSTED BELLMAN
DELAYS- ADDITIONALLY LAST YEAR
THE LET THE LEGISLATURE HEAD
OFFICE ABOUT SOME OF THE COLOR
FLEXIBILITY SO WHAT WE MIGHT
CONTINUE. SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF
ADDITIONS HERE- I'M GOING TO
MAYOR VISION PROPOSES TO PAY THE
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT SERVICES
OUTSIDE OF INDIVIDUAL BUDGETS
AND SELF DETERMINATION. AND THIS
WOULD BE CONSISTENT WITH OF
OTHER SERVICES THAT USE
PURCHASE. EVAN MATHIS. OF ON THE
COST SHARING PROGRAM THERE ARE
TWO FEES. ALL WERE SUSPENDED
DURING THE PANDEMIC- WE'RE
PROPOSING TO EXTEND THAT
SUSPENSION THROUGH DECEMBER
TWENTY TWO- BUT THEN IN JANUARY
ELEVATE THAT- FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL THRESHOLD TO SIX HUNDRED
PERCENT. THIS WOULD BE KIND OF
IN LINE WITH SOME OF THE OTHER
SUBSIDY PROGRAMS. AND THEN
FINALLY- ALTERNATIVE SERVICES
WHICH HELP TO MAKE SURE
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE THE
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS- ADDRESS THEIR-
IMMEDIATE NEEDS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. BUT ALSO SUPPORT THE
PROVIDER NETWORK IN SOME OF
THOSE A MORE CHALLENGING
INSTANCES. SO THE MAYOR VISION
PROPOSES LANGUAGE TO EXTEND THAT
THROUGH DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWO.
BUT ALSO TO PROVIDE MORE CHOICE
FOR INDIVIDUALS- AT THE TAYLOR
DAY SERVICE WHICH AGAIN RIGHT
INTO VISUALS MORE MORE CHOI
CHOICE IN THEIR SERVICES- AND
THEN TO HELP WITH PROVIDERS AND
SOME OF THOSE ADDRESSING THE
CHANGING SCHEDULES OF
INDIVIDUALS. ELIMINATE THE HALF
DAY BILLING- ADDITIONAL ITEMS
INCLUDING THE MAYOR VISION. OF
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE- ON GOING
PLANNING WITH THE CITY OF COSTA
MESA FOR THE DISPOSITION OF
FAIRVIEW- SOME ADDITIONAL
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PLANNING-
BUILDING OFF OF THE INVESTMENT
LAST YEAR. TO PROVIDE SOME
ONGOING RESOURCES- AND THEN A
NUMBER OF PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
DIRECTION GUIDANCE- WITH SOME OF
THESE PROPOSALS- FOR THE BILL
ALSO ADDRESSING ADDITIONAL
CHANGES. AND THEN- CAL POLY-
INCREASE COSTS FOR CONSTRUCTION
INDEX AS WELL AS
REAPPROPRIATION. OPPONENTS OF
CHRISTOPHER O'NEILL DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NOTHING FURTHER TO
ADD MR. SUN YOU PICK THE PLO IS
A THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- SONYA
PADDOCK WITH THE L. A. O. OKAY
WE JUST READ- OBVIOUSLY IN THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING ALL OF THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSALS WE'RE
GOING TO LIMIT OUR COMMENTS
TODAY TO THE PROPOSAL FOR WORK
FOR STABILITY- WE KNOW THAT.
THIS PROPOSAL IS MEANT TO
ADDRESS WHAT WE HEAR IS A BIG
AND GROWING AND IMMEDIATE
PROBLEMS IN THE DDS- SYSTEM BALL
FOR REGIONAL CENTERS AS WELL AS
SERVICE PROVIDERS- I GUESS OUR
COMMENTS WILL. COME DOWN TO TWO
MAIN POINTS HOWEVER ONE IS- ARE
THESE THE RIGHT SOLUTIONS TO
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM IN THE NEAR
TERM. AND THEN IN LIGHT OF THE
STATE'S- CHALLENGES WITH THE
STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT ARE
THESE PROPOSALS REALLY READY TO
GO- SO FOR EXAMPLE- THIS
PROPOSAL DOES NOT HAVE
ASSOCIATED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
SO IT'S HARD TO KNOW EXACTLY HOW
SOME OF THE INITIATIVESWOULD
WORK- ON BOTH THE TRAINING AND
INTERNSHIP COMPONENTS OF THE
PROPOSAL WERE NOT- CERTAIN THAT
THESE PROPOSALS WOULD
NECESSARILY SOLVE- THE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
PROBLEM AMONG THE- DIRECT
SERVICE PROVIDER- WORK FORCE-
POPULATION. AND THEN ON THE
PIECE THAT CONCERNS TUITION
REIMBURSEMENT FOR REGIONAL
CENTER STAFF WE BELIEVE THERE
ARE SOME- KEY DETAILS THAT ARE
LACKING FROM THE PROPOSAL. SO
FIRST- THE PROPOSAL DOES NOT
SPECIFY WHAT THE REQUIRED WORK
COMMITMENT WOULD BE FOLLOWING
RECEIPT OF THE TUITION
REIMBURSEMENT- IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THIS HAS NOT BEEN
DETERMINED YET M. BUT THE
LEGISLATURE. OBVIOUS INTEREST IN
MAKING SURE THAT IT GETS- SOME
BENEFIT FROM AN INVESTMENT IN
INDIVIDUALS EDUCATION- SECONDS
WE'RE NOT SURE IF THIS WILL BE
SORT OF AN IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGE OR NOT BUT DDS
INDICATED TO OUR OFFICE THAT
BECAUSE- HALF ABOUT HALF OF THE
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE UNIONIZED.
WHETHER THAT COULD- HAVE TO HAVE
SOME KIND OF INTERACTION WITH
THIS PARTICULAR PUZZLE TO
REIMBURSE SOME PEOPLE'S TUITION-
THAT'S JUST AN ISSUE WE HAVEN'T
GOTTEN TO THE BOTTOM OF YET-
THIRD IT'S SORT OF CLEAR WHICH
REGIONAL STAFF WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
WHO WOULD MAKE THIS
DETERMINATION AND WHAT CRITERIA
THAT WOULD BE BASED ON. AND THEN
LASTLY- THERE ARE SOME OTHER
JUST SMALL DETAILS THAT COULD
HAVE IMPLICATIONS AND NEED TO BE
IRONED OUT SO JUST FOR EXAMPLE
IN THE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE- IT
SPECIFIES THAT- THIS WOULD HELP
PAY FOR REGIONAL CENTER. STAFF
TO PURSUE ADVANCED DEGREES BUT
IT DOESN'T DEFINE WHAT AN
ADVANCE ADVANCED DEGREE IS IT'S
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT TYPICALLY
REFERS TO SERVE. POSTGRADUATE
AND GRADUATE- DEGREES BUT I
THINK- DDS WOULD LIKE THAT TO
ALSO APPLY TO UNDERGRADUATE
DEGREE SO THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
DETAILS THAT STILL NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT. IF YOU FROM THE
FUNDS THAT MISTER TERRA
CHRISTOPHER O'NEILL WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND JUST
IN RESPONSE I THINK WITH A
MINISTRATION LIKE TO SAY THAT
THE REVISION IS- CONTAINING TO
BUILD ON HENCE THE OVERALL WORK
FORCE STRATEGY WITHIN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM
AND THE PROPOSAL THAT YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU MAYOR VISION REALLY
FOCUSING ON THOSE ENTRY POINTS
AND HOLDING ON TO THOSE WORKERS
WHO ARE CURRENTLY IN THE SYSTEM
AND- SO WE THE MINISTRATIONS
SEES AS AS AS AS PART OF A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH AND YOUR
FOLLOWS UP ON VESTMENTS FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
INCLUDING- DSP UNIVERSITY WHICH
HAS- TRAINING. AND INTERIOR
CERTIFICATION DIFFERENTIALS FOR
STAFF AS WELL AS BILINGUAL PAY
DIFFERENTIALS FOR STAFF SAID
THANK YOU. YOU NEXT COULD WE
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT
SPEAKERS FOR THE CST MAY REVISE.
PROPOSALS PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS JASON
WIMBERLY CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT A PLACE
TO BE HERE TODAY TO PRESENT THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSALS THE FOR
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAYBE VISION. THE
FIRST PROPOSAL. THE CALIFORNIA
WHERE IT'S PAYMENT PROGRAM.
ESTABLISHED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT- CAP DIRECTED ONE
BILLION IN FEDERAL AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACT FUNDING TOWARDS
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO REDUCE
OR ELIMINATE PASSED TO. ENERGY
BILL BALANCES ACCRUED BY
CUSTOMERS ECONOMICALLY IMPACTED
BY THE COVE IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT
TWO BILLION IN FUNDING TO HELP
ADDRESS ENERGY RICHES ACCRUED.
ACCUMULATED BY CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS IMPACTED BY THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WELL CAP HAS
MADE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
REDUCING OR ELIMINATING. A
CALIFORNIA ENERGY DEBTS FOR
THESE- RIGHT FOOT- HE TOLD THE
CUSTOMERS. PUBLIC AND INVESTOR
OWNED ENERGY UTILITIES ARE
REPORTING OTHER PARISHES HAVE
CONTINUE TO GROW FOR THESE
CUSTOMERS. THE PROPOSAL POSITION
CAP TO RELIEVE THIS BURDEN BY
DRESSING AND HERE WE'RE JUST
EXPERIENCE BY CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS. AND CONTRIBUTE TO
THE STATE'S OUR DISASTER
RESPONSE TO ADDRESS THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE SECONDPROPOSAL
THE LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLD WATER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THE PROGRAM
PROVIDES FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA'S TO HELP
MANAGE THEIR RESIDENTIAL WATER
UTILITY COSTS. LIVE UP- WAS
CREATED UNDER THE FEDERAL
CONSOLIDATED APPROPRIATIONS ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN
CALIFORNIA SHARE ONE TIME
FEDERAL GRANT FUNDS IS A HUNDRED
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS. THE
CURRENT PROGRAM BRAND EXPENSIVE
PERIOD IS TWENTY JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THROUGH SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL
TWO HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME.
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL FISCAL
RECOVERY FUNDS TO SUPPLEMENT THE
FEDERAL ALLOCATION FOR THIS
PROGRAM IN THE ALLOW THE PROGRAM
TO CONTINUE AFTER THE FEDERAL
FUNDING- FUNDING EXPIRES IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY THREE-
THE PROGRAM THE PROPOSED
CONTINUATION OF THE PROGRAM
WOULD RUN THROUGH JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. THE THIRD PROPOSAL
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY
WEATHERIZATION ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. CST REQUESTS A ONE TIME
INCREASE IN FEDERAL FUNDADOR THE
OF A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE POINT
THREE MILLION TO UTILIZE
SUPPLEMENTAL FEDERAL DEPARTMENT
OF ENERGY WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
GRANT FUNDS. THIS FUNDING WAS
APPROPRIATED UNDER THE FEDERAL
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE LAW.
CST RECEIVES AN ANNUAL GRANT.
ALLOCATION OF- WHAT WHAT IS A
SIN SYSTEMS FRONTS FROM DEAL WE
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS- THIS
PROPOSAL APPROVED BY PRESENTS NO
INCREASED COST OF THE STATE. CST
HAS BEGUN THE PROCESS OF
CONSULTING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
SPECIFICALLY OUR LOCAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS ON PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING. THE
PROBABLY THE SERIES OF PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENTS OVER THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE DEAL BASIC
PLAN THAT'S REQUIRED FOR THIS%
FUNDING. THE STATE PLANS
REQUIRED TO BE SUBMITTED TO DOT
FOR THEIR APPROVAL BY OCTOBER.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO- THE FNAL
PROPOSAL- IS UP. FOR RE
APPROPRIATION A QUEST. FOR LOW
LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WITH SOLAR
PHOTOVOLTAIC SYSTEMS AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY UPGRADES AT NO COST.
ALSO THIS PROGRAMS CONSIDER WHEN
THE CLASS- CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS WHICH HELPS REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY
SAVING ENERGY AND GENERATING
CLEAN RENEWABLE POWER. LIVE UP
ALSO REDUCES- ENERGY EXPENSES
FOR LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
STRENGTHENING THEIR ECONOMIC
SECURITY. OVER THE COURSE OF HIS
EXISTENCE THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM HAS BEEN
FUNDED BY DIFFERENT FUNDING
APPROPRIATIONS EACH WITH ITS OWN
LIQUIDATION TIME FRAME. THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES THAT IMPACT
THE CONSTRUCTION TIMELINES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROPERTIES
ACCESS AND LIVE WITH FUNDING
PREVENTING THE COMPLETION BY
JUNE THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR. CST
IS REQUESTING THE APPROPRIATION
TO SECURE AN ADDITIONAL YEAR OF
LIQUIDATION AUTHORITY TO FOR
THESE FUNDS APPROPRIATED VIA THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THIS ADDITIONAL FOR YOUR OF
LIQUIDATION AUTHORITY WILL
ENABLE THE PROGRAM TO FILL
FUNDING COMMITMENTS TO IMPACT
THE PROJECTS NOT SURE THE
COMPLETION OVER THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR. THAT CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION AND HAPPEN ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES TWO WILL BAKER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT
THAN THAT AT THIS TIME BUT HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. HELLO
THANK YOU ANGELES SHORT WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M
JUST A BRIEF COMMENT REGARDING
THE PROPOSED ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION FOR
THE CALIFORNIA RICH PAYMENT
PROGRAM OR CAP- WE DO ANTICIPATE
RECEIVING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE-
WHICH WILL BE. REVIEWING TO- SS
ANY SIGNIFICANT PROPOSED
IMPLEMENTATION CHANGES BUT BASED
ON OUR INITIAL REVIEW WE DO
BELIEVE THIS PROPOSAL HAS MERIT-
AS YOU HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT
AND AS WE'VE DISCUSSED IN
PREVIOUS HEARINGS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. THE INITIAL ONE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE PROGRAM-
WAS ALLOCATED UP QUITE QUICKLY
IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND HAS
PROVIDED MORE THAN ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITH ON DEBT RELIEF
DURING THE PANDEMIC- SO WE DO
SEE THE- PROPOSED AUGMENTATION
AS ADDRESSING A CLEARLY
ASSESSED- NEED ASSOCIATED WITH
THE PANDEMIC- BUT WE WILL
CERTAINLY RAISE ANY NEW CONCERNS
OR ISSUES AS WE'RE ABLE TO
REVIEW THE DETAILS LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT COULD
BE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION SPEAKERS FOR THE
D. O. MADE REVISED PROPOSALS.
JUST DOUBLE CLICK IT SURE
MEMBERS. PLEASE BEGIN DIRECTOR
XAVIER WHEN YOU'RE READY GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ON
THE TWO PROPOSALS BEFORE US AND
IS CERTAINLY DOUBTS AND
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE- INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES- OR OLDER
ADULTS WERE EITHER
INSTITUTIONALIZED OR AT RISK. OF
BEING INSTITUTIONALIZED. NEED
THE SUPPORT EITHER TO REMAIN
INDEPENDENTLY IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES ARE TO TRANSITION
OUT OF THE INSTITUTIONS. AND THE
DISABILITY AND AGING NETWORKS
NEED TO CONTINUE TO DEVELOP
THEIR CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO
MEET- THIS NEED OF TRANSITION.
AND DIVERSION ADDITIONALLY OFTEN
TIMELY WRAPAROUND SERVICES OF
NEEDED TO BOTH KEEP INDIVIDUALS
OUT OF INSTITUTIONS. AND TO HELP
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN
JUST SITUATIONS TO TRANSITION TO
THE COMMUNITY. THE FUNDS THAT WE
ARE ASKING FOR THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS OVER ASKING FOR THE
PROPOSAL- PROVIDE A GAP FOR INTO
FOR SERVICES THAT ARE NOT
AVAILABLE THROUGH OTHER PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES THEY CAN PROVIDE
IT. JUST IN TIME THOSE CAN
INCLUDE THINGS SUCH AS RENT
ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY AND
PERSONAL ASSISTANCE. AND SERVICE
FUND WOULD PRO PROVIDE A BRIDGE
TO OTHER SERVICES THAT
INDIVIDUALS MAY NEED SO THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY. SO IN ADDITION TO
EXPANDING THAT CAPACITY IN
GETTING PEOPLE OUT OF THE
COMMUNITIES- WE ARE LOOKING
CERTAINLY TO- ASSESS THE THIS
PILOT THEY WERE PUTTING TOGETHER
AND CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
SHARING. THE RESULTS OF THAT
PART OF IT WITH POLICY THIS IS
WELLS OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND
LOCAL SYSTEMS. THE ELIGIBILITY
FOR THIS PROGRAM OR INDIVIDUALS
WHO. ARE NOT ON THAT ACCOUNT IN
ORDER 3100% OR LESS OF POVERTY
LEVEL. OR INTO WHOSE INCOMES A
3100% OR LESS- OF POVERTY LEVEL.
AND THEN ALSO INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAY BE A MEDIC CAL- BUT DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO THE SERVICES THAT
ARE NEEDED TO GET OUT OF THE
COMMUNITY. SO THE OTHER THING
THAT I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THE
OTHER ITEMS THAT WE BRING FOR
YOU TODAY IS- THE- ALIGNMENT OF
OUR JOB COACHING RATES WITH. THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. SO THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES CONTINUE
TO ADVANCE COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS OF MOST SIGNIFICANT
DISABILITIES INCLUDING
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AND JOB COACHING
IS A SERVICE THAT IS THE CENTRAL
BOTH TO GETTING A JOB AND TO
KEEPING THAT CHILD. AND GIVEN
THE D. O. R. AND THE DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES OFTEN USE
THE SAME PROVIDERS TO SERVE
MUTUAL CONSUMERS CONFORMING
THOSE RATES- IS ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURE THERE'S NO DISPARITY- IN
THE IN THE SERVICES AND THE
RIGHTS PROVIDED. AND SO
ACCORDINGLY WE ARE LOOKING FOR
ONE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
THERE TO CONFORM TO THE RATES
THAT THE DDS WILL ALSO BE
CHANGING- IN THERE. AND THE
PROPOSED BUDGET. SO GLAD TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS- THAT YOU HAVE FOR
US. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NOTHING THAT AT THIS TIME BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
HELLO. SENATE HEADED WITH THE L.
A. O. ON THE LATTER POINTS-
REGARDING CONFORMING TO YOUR
RATES TO DDS RATES THAT MAKES
SENSE AND THAT WOULD REFLECT
PAST PRACTICE- SO WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS THERE. ON THE FORMER
PROPOSAL THE COMMUNITY LIVING
PROPOSAL- WE ARE STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING THAT WE
JUST HAVEN'T RECEIVED THE ACTUAL
B. C. P. TODAY SO WE'LL GET BACK
TO YOUR STAFF WITH- ANY. THANK
YOU NEXT WE HAVE THE DEPARTMENT
OF CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES TO
PRESENT THE P. C. S. S. MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS.
THANKS GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
ANGELA MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE- NAN CHEN CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT I JUST WANT TO
QUICKLY GO OVER IN THE FINANCE
LETTER- DEPARTMENTS REQUESTING
THE MAYOR VISION A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT OF ABOUT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO SHIFT FUNDING FROM.
THE CHILD- THE CHILD SUPPORT
RECOVERY FUND WHICH ESSENTIALLY
IS THE FEDERAL SHARE OF
ASSISTANCE RECORD COLLECTIONS
AND WE'RE GOING TO REDUCE THAT
BY ABOUT A MILLION DOLLARS
BECAUSE WE'RE ESTIMATING THAT
ASSISTANCE QUESTIONS ARE GOING
TO DEAL. MORE THAN WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AN INCREASE
THE FEDERAL TRUST FUND. BY
MILLION DOLLARS SO IT'S IN THAT
ZERO ADJUSTMENT BECAUSE WE'RE
GONNA DRAW DOWN ADDITIONAL
FUNDS- HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. BERMAN FINANCED
NOTHING AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
HELLO. ELLIOTT NO CONTENT THANK
YOU FINALLY COULD WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
SPEAKERS FOR THE DSSME REVISED
PROPOSALS.
RECTOR JOHNSON BEGIN MERIT THANK
YOU SO MUCH CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CAN JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES HOPE ALSO PROVIDE A
BRIEF AND HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW
THE SIGNIFICANT ISSUES OUTLINED
IN THE MAY FIND ITS LETTER- I
JUST AGAIN AB REALLY GRATEFUL TO
BE HERE AND TALK ABOUT AT THE
AREAS OF CONTINUED IMPROVEMENT
ON THOSE WE HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
TO SERVE. DEPUTY DIRECTOR SHORTS
WILL START WITH OUR CHILD
WELFARE MAY REVISION PROPOSALS.
HAPPENING HERE EVERY BILL AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANGIE
SCHWARTZ DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES
DIVISION I'LL PROVIDE A QUICK
SUMMARY OF THE KEY INVESTMENTS
TO SUPPORT. OUR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES FIRST. THE EXCELLENCE
IN FAMILY FINDING AN ENGAGEMENT
PROGRAM WE PROPOSE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION. GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME- BLOCK GRANT. TO BE
EXPENDED OVER FIVE YEARS TO
SUPPORT. THE HIRING OF DEDICATED
PERMANENCY SPECIALISTS- THIS IS
IN ADDITION TO THAT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND FROM. GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET TO SUPPORT CONTINUOUS
TRAINING AND SUPPORT OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE HIRED. I'M
THROUGH THIS INVESTMENT. SECOND
NINE HUNDRED INSTEAD WE PROPOSE
NINE HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND IN ORDER. SUPPORT
PLACEMENTS. YOU ARE. NEWLY
ESTABLISHED BUT NOT YET
ACCREDITED SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAM
FACILITIES IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
WE CAN CONTINUE TO BUILD THAT
CAPACITY- THE FAMILY FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT REQUIRES
THOSE. FACILITIES TO BE
ACCREDITED BEFORE THE FEDERAL
FUNDS CAN BEGIN TO FLOW BUT
THERE'LL BE A PERIOD OF TIME
WHILE THEY'RE WORKING TO GET
ACCREDITED THAT WE STILL WANT TO
BE ABLE TO PLACE CHILDREN. IN
THOSE FACILITIES. I'M IN
ADDITION WE PROPOSE TEN POINT
FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THE TRANSITION OF OUR S.
T. R. T. P. PROVIDERS. AWAY FROM
I'M BEING CONSIDERED- UNDER THE
I. M. D. RULE OR THEY WOULD LOSE
HER MEDICAID FUNDING SO THAT
MONEY WILL HELP TO CONTINUE TO
ALLOW OUR S. T. R. T. PIECE TO
MAKE THAT TRANSITION- AWAY
CHANGING THEIR PROGRAM MODELS
ARE BRINGING THEIR CAPACITY DOWN
BELOW SIXTEEN BEDS. I'M IN
ADDITION THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES FOUR POINT NINE MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN ORDER TO ALLOW
OUR EMERGENCY CARE GIVERS TO
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE. SUPPORT
BEYOND NINETY DAYS AND UP TO A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS. AND IF
THAT APPROVAL- IS TAKING LONGER
THAN NINETY DAYS AND THERE IS
GOOD CAUSE TO ESTABLISH THE
REASON. FOR WHY THERE'S BEEN A
DELAY BEYOND THE NINETY DAYS.
THERE'S ALSO A PROPOSAL FOR
FIFTY MILLION GENERAL FUND- IN
ORDER TO SUPPORT CARE GIVER
APPROVALS THAT'S ONGOING FUNDING
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
COUNTY WELFARE AGENCIES ARE ABLE
TO REDUCE. THE RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL TIMELINES. AND FINALLY-
THERE IS A ONE TIME INVESTMENT
OF TWENTY FIVE MILLION IN ORDER
TO SUPPORT PLACEMENT AND
SERVICES OF OUR YOUTH WHO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED- AND VICTIMS OF
COMMERCIAL SEXUAL EXPLOITATION
IN ORDER TO ALLOW US TO. EXPAND
OR SUPPORT NEW PILOTS TO USE- TO
SERVE THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE. WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND I'LL TURN IT BACK
TO DIRECTOR JOHNSON TO COVER THE
REMAINING PROPOSALS THANK YOU
ALSO MENTIONED THAT PROPOSAL FOR
A HUNDRED AND EIGHT MILLION
TOTAL FUNDS AND THIRTY FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION. AND
PROVISIONAL AUTHORITY FOR THE
CONTINUED DEVELOPMENT OF OUR
CHILD WELFARE INFORMATION SYSTEM
OUR CARES PROJECT. MOVING ON TO
OUR CAL WORKS IN CASH ASSISTANCE
I WOULD ALSO PROVIDE YOU WITH
SOME CASELOAD ESTATES THE
REVISED HOW WORKS CASELOAD FOR
BUDGET YEAR- IS A SEVEN POINT 5%
DECREASE COMPARED TO GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BUT STILL REPRESENTS A
PROJECTED INCREASE OF ALMOST 21%
FROM CURRENT YEAR. FEMEI
REVISION INCLUDES AT SIX POINT
FIVE BILLION TOTAL FUNDS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR CAO
WORKS. IN ALSO REFLECTS AT 11%
INCREASE TO THE COW WORKS
MAXIMUM EIGHT PAYMENT LEVELS
WHICH IS ESTIMATED TO COST TWO
HUNDRED NINETY SIX POINT TWO
MILLION. THESE EIGHT INCREASE
GRANTS ARE COOKED FUNDED
ENTIRELY BY THE CHILD POVERTY
AND FAMILY SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORTS
THAT ACCOUNT OF THE LOCAL
REVENUE FUND. THE INCREASE WILL
BRING THE NON EXEMPT MAP LEVEL
FROM NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS TO ONE THOUSAND
TWENTY SEVEN PER MONTH FOR AN
ASSISTANCE UNIT SIZE OF THREE.
RESIDING IN A HIGH COST COUNTY
REALLY GLAD TO HAVE AN INCREASED
NUMBER THEIR FROM GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AS IT RELATES TO FOOD
SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE ARE
CALFRESH CASELOAD- HAS ACTUALLY
A 7% DECREASE FROM GOOD COMPARED
TO GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT STILL
REPRESENTS A PROJECTED INCREASE
OF TWO POINT 4% FROM CURRENT
YEAR. AT THE MARY VISION
INCLUDES THIRTEEN POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL FUNDS SIX
POINT EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES
TO COMPLY WITH CHAPTER FIVE
SEVENTY STATUTES OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OR AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SIX WHICH REQUIRES. THE COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICE AGENCY SAYS THAT
DESIGNATED STAFF LIAISON.
INFORMATION FROM PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES TO STUDENTS AND HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS. ALSO
NOTE THAT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD UPDATE THE CALFRESH
ADMIT CREATIVE. EASING TO. THE
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR INSTEAD OF AT BUDGET YEAR.
AS A REALLY TO IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES ARE REVIVED
CASELOAD AT IS SIX HUNDRED ONE
THOUSAND FOUR EIGHT ZERO POINT
3% INCREASE COMPARED TO
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. I WE ARE GLAD
AN APPRECIATIVE OF WORKING WITH
MANY STAKEHOLDERS RELATED TO OUR
PERMANENT BACKUP PROVIDER
SYSTEM. IN THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES THIRTY FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION TOTAL FUNDS FIFTEEN
POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
ON GOING TO ESTABLISH THAT
SYSTEM. WE ADDITIONALLY-
RELATIVE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET HAVE UPDATED THE PROPOSAL
TO ALLOW TRANSITION PERIOD FROM
JULY OF THIS YEAR TO OCTOBER TO
ALLOW FOR THE TRANSITION OF THE
EMERGENCY BACKUP PROVIDER SYSTEM
TO THE PERMANENT BACKUP PROVIDER
SYSTEM. COSTS HAVE ALSO BEEN
REVISED TO REFLECT SOME OF THAT
WORK WE'VE DONE THE STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING AT INCREASING THE
ANNUAL LIMIT FROM EIGHTY HOURS
TO ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY HOURS.
ALSO KNOWN AS A CASELOAD UPDATE
THE REVISED SS I SS P. CASELOAD-
IS THE ONE POINT ONE INCREASE
COMPARED TO GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AS IT RELATES TO OUR IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION EFFORTS WE HAVE OF
THE GOVERNORS MAY VISION
PROPOSAL INCLUDES A ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
AVAILABILITY OVER TWO YEARS TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
MIGRANT ARRIVALS AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IN FUNDING FOR A RANGE OF
EMERGING. ISSUES RELATED TO
MIGRANT SUPPORT SERVICES AND
CASE MANAGEMENT TARGETED
DISASTER RELIEF SIMILAR. AT TO
PRIOR RESPONSES TO CRITICAL NEED
THAT WE'VE BEEN UTILIZING THAT
FUND FOR. THE GREAT REVISION
ALSO CONCLUDES A PROPOSAL FOR
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT. THE
EXISTING COHORT ESTABLISHED BY
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
ACT PILOT PROGRAM. IN THIS AGAIN
AIMS TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
REMOVABLE REMOVAL DEFENSE FOR.
THAT ATTORNEYS IN THE CAPACITY
OF NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE REMOVAL DEFENSE SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL COAST
AND CENTRAL VALLEY. AND FINALLY.
AT THE TWENTY TWO MAY REVISION
INCLUDES A ONE TIME PASSED
THROUGH A TWELVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND AVAILABLE OVER THREE YEARS
TO SUPPORT. FOR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE NO LONGER
RECEIVING FEDERAL FUNDS FROM THE
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM FOCUSES ON
REVITALIZING ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THROUGH THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
CRADLE TO CAREER NETWORK OF
SERVICES. AIM TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH SAFETY IN EDUCATION AT
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS IN DEFINED
AREAS. THOSE FOUR AREAS INCLUDE
CHULA VISTA CORNING HAYWARD IN
MISSION PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND OF COURSE WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
AT CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
SUBSIDY INVESTMENTSTHAT ARE
BEING HEARD IN SUB TO BUT WITH
THAT WE CONCLUDE OUR OVERVIEW.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IN PERSON%
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD BUT HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS HELLO CHECK
THE PROCEDURE LMAO WE'RE STILL
IN THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING ALL
OF THE MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND INCLUDED IN THAT
REVIEW IS- LOOKING OVER THE
CASELOAD ESTIMATES BECAUSE AS
YOU KNOW CASELOAD ESTIMATES AND
CAL WORK SITE JUST SAYS THIS I
SUSPECT YOU DO HAVE IMPLICATIONS
FOR I'M PROGRAM COST- ONE THING
THAT WE WOULD FLAG ON THE
EXERCISES PIECE SIDE THOUGH IS-
AS A WAS BROUGHT UP IN JANUARY.
THE GOVERNOR HAS SIGNALED AN
INTENTION TO- INCREASE S. S. P.
GRANTS IN JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR SO BUDGET YOUR PLUS ONE-
BASED OFF OF THE REVISED
CASELOAD ESTIMATES IN MAY OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT SINCE
CASELOAD CAYMAN- JUST SLIGHTLY
HIGHER RELATIVE TO JANUARY
ESTIMATES BECAUSE CASE THAT
ISN'T GROW ISN'T DECLINING AS
QUICKLY AS INITIALLY THOUGHT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS REVISED ITS
BEST AS P. GRANT INCREASE
ESTIMATE FROM ABOUT TWENTY FOUR
PERCENT. TO ABOUT TWENTY
PERCENT- AND AGAIN THAT S. S. P.
GRADE INCREASE WOULD TAKE EFFECT
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR SO
WHILE- THE ACTUAL GRANT INCREASE
WON'T BE FINALIZED UNTIL NEXT
YEAR IT'S JUST AN. EXAMPLE OF A
WHITE. WE'RE GOING TO JUST BE
LOOKING AT OF US MORE TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF NOT JUST
BUDGET YOUR APPLICATIONS BY YOUR
IMPLICATIONS. AND THEN WITHOUT
ME TO PASS IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE ANGELA SHORT FOR
COMMENTS ON THE CHILD WELFARE
PROPOSALS. HUH THANK YOU ANGELES
SHORT WITH YELLOW- JUST A FEW
COMMENTS IN PARTICULAR REGARDING
THE PROPOSALS OF THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A CARE GIVER
APPROVALS ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR- FAMILY
FINDING AN ENGAGEMENT GRANTS.
AND THE FOUR POINT NINE MILLION-
TO CONTINUE PROVIDING EMERGENCY
CARE GIVERS WITH FUNDING PRIOR
TO APPROVAL BEYOND NINETY DAYS-
OVERALL BASED ON OUR PRELIMINARY
REVIEW WE DO FIND THAT THESE
PROPOSALS ALIGNED WITH THE-
OVERARCHING GOALS OF THE CHILD
WELFARE CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM. AND CONCEPT WOULD REPORT
CRITICAL COMPONENTS OF THE
FUNCTIONING OF THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM- NAMELY ENSURING THAT
SUFFICIENT NUMBERS OF RESOURCE
FAMILIES CAN BE APPROVED IN A
TIMELY MANNER. AND HELPING TO
REACH THEIR GOAL OF PLACING
FOSTER YOUTH- WITH RELATIVES AND
FAMILY BASED SETTINGS TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE- IN PARTICULAR
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE AREAS OF
CARE GIVER PRIVIL AND PLACEMENT
PRIOR TO APPROVAL- ARE AREAS
WHERE WE HAVE PREVIOUSLY
DISCUSSED POTENTIAL UP THE
POTENTIAL NEED FOR AUGMENTATIONS
- THAT SAID WE ARE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ENSURE WE FULLY UNDERSTAND HOW
THEY ARRIVED AT THE- THE
SPECIFIC BUDGET FIGURE. THE
FIFTY MILLION FOR THE CHARACTER
FOR APPROVAL- AND WE WILL FOLLOW
UP AS WE LEARN MORE AND ALSO AND
BE SURE TO ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO- TO UNDERSTAND-
THE FULL NEED FOR RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL FUNDING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THAT IS THE
CONCLUSION THE PANELISTS FOR NOW
I WILL ASK YOU TO STAY JUST FOR
A FEW QUESTIONS IF I CAN. I WILL
LOOK TOWARDS OTHER MEMBERS I
WILL KEEP IT HERE AT THE CHAIR
TO BEGIN. I'M I'M GOING TO KEEP
IT WITH THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM IF I CAN AND REALLY
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THE FAMILY
FINDING SUPPORT AND THE
ENGAGEMENT. GRANT DID PRIOR
APPROPRIATIONS FOR FAVORS
INCLUDING A COUNTY MATCH. ISN'T
THE ADMINISTRATION CONCERNS THAT
A COUNTY MATCH COULD RESULT IN
UNEQUAL TREATMENT FOR FOSTER
YOUTH ACROSS COUNTIES HOPING YOU
COULD COMMENT ON THAT I'LL START
WITH THE SECOND MOVIE TURNS MY
IT AT CALLING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- AS IT RELATES TO THE
AND EVEN IMPLEMENTATION WHAT WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE FAMILY
FINDING A RESPONSIBILITY IS A
RESPONSIBILITY THAT EXISTS
TODAY. I WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE IS LEVERAGING THOSE
FUNDS IN THOSE RESOURCES USING
AGAIN WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED WORKS
IN OUR EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
AT FURTHER AGAIN LEVERAGE THOSE
FUNDS AND CONTINUE THAT EFFORT-
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY INTENDING TO-
TAKE THE LESSONS LEARNED IN THE
AT BEST PRACTICES OUT OF THAT
COMPONENT AND APPLY THEM
UNIVERSALLY THE MATTER WHETHER
OR NOT A COUNTY IS
PARTICIPATING. AT SPECIFICALLY
IN THIS COMPONENT OF THE PROGRAM
SO THERE WILL BE A UNIVERSAL
APPLICATION IN THAT IN THAT
SENSE IN TERMS OF THOSE
PRACTICES BUT RELATED TO PEPPERS
I WILL TURN OVER TO JUST
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF FINANCING
I THINK ONE THING IS CLEAR
WHETHER THE THAT'S A GOOD HAVE
BEEN SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE FLIPPERSFUNDING.
FAMILY FUN AND SO THE PAPER
SPENDING WAS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE CONTINUING
CARE REFORM THE IDEA WAS THAT AS
A RUNS WHERE TRANSITIONING YOUTH
FROM A CONGREGATE CARES INTO
HOME BASED ON THE CARE SETTINGS
AT A QUICK PROCESS- THE
MINISTRATION AND KNOWLEDGE THAT
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WOULD
NEED TO BE EXPEDITED SO THE
RESULT FROM FUNDING PUT INTO A
SUPPLEMENT. AS DIRECTOR JOHNSONSAID THE COUNTY RESPONSIBILITIES
ALREADY THEY WERE REALIGNED FOR
THEM FOR FAMILY FIND IT SO
COMPARING THE TWO IS A SLIGHTLY
A THINK A LITTLE MISLEADING
BECAUSE OF THAT NOW WITH THE
COUNTY MATCH- WE THINK THAT THAT
THE IDEA THIS IS TO SUPPLEMENT
AGAIN THOSE ACTIVITIES AND THIS
IS A CORE FUNCTION FOR COUNTIES
IN THE IDEAS TO HELP.
INCENTIVIZE WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE
MAKING SURE THAT THE YOUTH ARE
PUT INTO PLACE AND THAT IS FOR
THEIR NEEDS SO WE DON'T SEE THAT
THERE WOULD BE AN IN EQUITY
THERE- BECAUSE AGAIN THESE ARE
RECENT THESE ARE ACTIVITIES THAT-ALREADY COUNT SHOULD BE. DOING
ANA REQUIRED TO DO THROUGH. TO
ELEVEN RELY RELATE. IT FOR SOME
OF US WE LIKE. AND SINCE
VISITATION IT'S WHETHER CERTAIN
COUNTIES WILL GET LEFT BEHIND
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT MATCHING
THOSE FUNDS AND US THAT'S THE
INEQUITY THAT WERE CONCERNED
WITH IS A FOR LEAVING IT UP TO
THE COUNTIES TO PUT THEIR
PORTION NOT. I UNDERSTAND WE'RE
TRYING TO LEVERAGE I JUST. AM
WORRIED ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS
OF THAT DECISION UNTIL IT
CAPITAL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR NOW
IF WE CAN. IF I'M IT JUST ONE
MORE COMING ON THAT RECOGNIZING
THAT THAT IT WAS A THAT WAS PART
OF THE POINT OF TWO THOUSAND
REALIGNMENT. COUNTIES DO YOU
HAVE A LOOK AT A LOCAL CONTROL
WHERE THEY CAN IDENTIFY AND
PRIORITIZE WHERE THEIR FUNDING
WHERE THEY WOULD LIKE TO ON
THEIR SERVICES BUT RECOGNIZE
THOSE COMMENTS. THANK YOU- I'LL
MOVE ON TO CALFRESH ELIGIBILITY
FUNDING IF I CAN. IT SEEMS THAT
THERE CONTINUES TO BE A SIXTY
MILLION DOLLAR DEFICIENCY IN THE
MAY REVISION. FOR CALIFORNIA'S
ELIGIBILITY. CAN YOU HELP US. TO
TELL US ABOUT WHAT THE CLIENT
IMPACTS WOULD BE OF THIS UNDER
FUNDING. WHAT KINDS OF DELAYS IN
PROCESSING ARE WE SEEING. HOPING
TO GET AN ANSWER ON THAT IF
POSSIBLE. JUSTIN FREITAS ONE OF
FINANCE I WITH MY COLLEAGUES-
GINNY DOCTOR WHO IS ON A JOURNEY
THROUGH AN EXTRA CAN RESPOND TO.
SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS. MAN
MISTER ACTOR IF YOU'RE
AVAILABLE. YEAH HI I. JEANINE DR
DEPART. IM SERVICE SO I CAN HELP
YOU OUT THERE A LITTLE BIT I AM
SO WHILE THE ADMINISTRATION IS
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
EVALUATING THE CALL FRESH
ELIGIBILITY FUNDING METHODOLOGY
420-232-2020 FOUR IT WILL BE
WORKING WITH YOU TO BE TODAY AND
COUNTIES ARE NOT EVALUATION- AND
WE HAVE REVIEWED THE SIXTY
MILLION DOLLAR- BUDGET YOUR
REQUEST WOULD DETECT WHICH DID
COMPASS YOU WTXF. WE WE NOTE
SOME CONCERNS. THAT SIXTY
MILLION DOLLAR ESTIMATE USED IN
THE PAST YEAR AGGREGATE DATA TO
PROJECTED OVER EXPENDITURE OF
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR DESPITE THE REQUEST
BEING MADE FOR BUDGET HERE. I'M
IN THE CURRENT YEAR COUNTY
ELIGIBILITY ALLOCATION IS BEING
HEALTH LOT INFAMY REVISION
DESPITE A 5% DECREASE IN
PROJECTED BRING YOUR CASELOAD
COMPARED TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET- ENACTMENT
PROJECTIONS- REVISION IS ALSO
PRETTY A PER D. AND BUDGET YOUR
CASELOAD COMPARED TO GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROJECTIONS WOULDN'T THAT
SIXTY MILLION DOLLAR ESTIMATE
WAS MADE- SO ESSENTIALLY UP.
YOUR POINT OF COMPARISON ISN'T
EXACTLY. PERFECT THERE ARE AND
ONCE WE ARE ABLE TO ENGAGE IN
GETTING COUNTY IS INSIDE
EVERYDAY AND COLLECT SURVEY DATA
WILL BE BETTERPOSITIONED
UNDERSTANDS THE UNDERLYING
CALFRESH ELIGIBILITY COSTS. MY
HOPE IS THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS TO THOSE
WHO ARE RECEIVING SERVICES AND
SO- IT AT SOME POINT TO- WE
SEEING. CALL CENTER WAIT TIMES
GOING UP ARE WE SAYING HANG UPS
ARE WE SEEING TRENDS AND
DISCONTINUANCE SAYS ERROR RATES.
THESE OCCUR WHEN WE DON'T HAVE
THE APPROPRIATE ELIGIBILITY
FUNDING AND I'M HOPING TO SEE IF
WE ARE NOTICING ANY TRENDS-
BECAUSE OF THE DECISIONS WE MAY
MAKE. SO I THINK FOR SOME OF THE
STUFF AND QUESTIONS ARE UP TO
DEFERRED TO- DIRECTOR JOHNSON
BUT- I TO REITERATE I BELIEVE
IT'S A I KNOW THE IT WAS A
LITTLE DIFFICULT FOR OF THE-
AUDIO THERE. BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION ON REBATES
IN LOOKING THE METHODOLOGY FOR
THE ADMINISTRA ADMINISTRATION
COMPONENT OF THE CALIPHATE'S
PROGRAM- JUST A TO ME FALLS A
LITTLE BIT ON WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
SAID IT'S JUST. THE SIXTY
MILLION DOLLAR- PROPOSAL FROM
CANADA FOR DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WE JUST WE COULDN'T TIED
TOGETHER HOW THAT WAS ASSOCIATE
WHERE WHERE THE WORKLOAD WAS IT
WAS BEING MESSED- SO AGAIN WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO WORK ON.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT A
SINGLE PAYER ADVOCATES ARE IN
AGREEMENT TO WORK ON THAT
METHODOLOGY NEXT YEAR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES SO IT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO. BEING ABLE TO ANSWER
AND THEN ADDRESS- WITH THE
LEGISLATURE NEXT YEAR IN IN IN
SURE I'M HAPPY TO SHARE
PROGRAMMATIC LEE APPLICATION
PROCESSING TIMES HAVE NOT BEEN
IMPACTED AS THE TIMELINESS OF
THE THIRTY DAY PROCESSING. HAS
STAYED RELATIVELY THE SAME OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS THE
TIMELINESS OF EXPEDITED
SERVICES- HAS DECREASED BY
ROUGHLY 8% SO THAT JUST IN TERMS
OF RETURN QUESTION WANTED TO
PROVIDE THAT. I'M SURE WE MIGHT
HEAR FROM C. W. D. EIGHT LATER
ON THIS- BUT WOULD ASK EIGHT CAN
ONE FINAL QUESTION S. S. BEFORE
I MOVED TO DDS. AND IT'S RELATED
TO THE CAL WORKS. SINGLE
ALLOCATION FUNDING. A WHAT FOR.
IS YOUR DEPARTMENT HEARING ABOUT
THE CONSTRAINTS ON ELIGIBILITY
PROCESSING. AND THE IMPACTS ON
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
SPECIFICALLY. GIVEN THE FUNDING
DEFICIENCY THAT WE'RE HEARING
ABOUT WITHIN SINGLE ALLOCATION.
WHICH CONTINUES TO BE AN ISSUE
HERE AT THE MAY REVISION HOPING
YOU CAN COME AND TO SHARE
SIMILARLY I WOULD JUST SAY. GET
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE HAVE
CONVERSATION WITH COUNTIES MAY
HAVE. ADDITIONAL NEEDS THAT IT'S
BEEN NOW THREE YEARS SINCE WE
HAVE IMPLEMENTED THE AGREED UPON
METHODOLOGY WHERE WE LOOKED AT
THAT. FORMULA THAT WAS AROUND
INCREMENTS THAT HE BELIEVES IN
CHILE THE INCREMENTS BASED ON
CASE LOW TO JUST MINCE WOULD
HAPPEN. ONLY SO OFTEN AND- WHAT
I WOULD JUST SAY IT HOLISTICALLY
AS WE ARE GLAD TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS AROUND HOW
FREQUENTLY- WE ACTUALLY TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT METHODOLOGY- GOING
FORWARD AT. IT AGAIN IT WAS- ALL
OF OUR BEST THINKING AT THE TIME
WE ARE APPLYING IT WE ARE
HEARING FROM THE COUNTIES THAT
CONCERNED- SO WE WANT TO.
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS TO ENSURE
THAT AGAIN ULTIMATELY ALL THE
WORKING INVESTMENT WE PUT INTO
SUPPORT AT THOSE FAMILIES AT IS
TRUE SO GLAD TO CONTINUE TO TALK
FURTHER. INTRODUCTORY THE MONEY
RESPONDED IN A BIG. THERE ALSO
IS SOME CLARIFICATION AS WE
PROVIDED ON HOW THE FUNDING IS
SURVIVOR CAL WORKS AS WELL WITH
WITH A PROPOSAL SO. CAL WORKS
ADMINISTRATION FUNDING IS. BASED
OFF A CASELOAD SO FOR EXAMPLE WE
HAD AN ESTIMATED CASELOAD AT THE
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT FOR NOW
WHICH IS CURRENT YEAR. ENDS IF
WE FUNDS WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THE STATE PROVIDES A LEVEL
FUNDING EQUAL TO WHAT WE THINK
THAT CASE WILL BE WHEN WE DO OUR
REVIVED THE GOVERNOR'S REVISED
BUDGET. I WITH THE REVISED
FORECASTED CASELOAD. CANCELED
WAS A GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR
CURRENT YEAR WAS M. REVISED TO
BE DOWN. AND THEN IT GOVERNOR'S
ADMIT REVISION HURTING A
FURTHER. WELL WE WOULD REDUCE
WHAT WE THINK THE CASE IT WILL
BE BASED ON THE PRODUCTION WE
DON'T PULL BACK THAT FUNDING
ASSOCIATED. MEN AND THAT'S BEEN
THE CASE SINCE- THE INITIAL
PANDEMIC SO WE'VE ASSUMED
ANYTHING VALLEY I WOULD AGREE ON
THIS. WE ORIGINALLY- COLLECTOR
I'LL TRANSFER OUT WHAT WAS GOING
HAPPEN QUESO. WE FUNDED THE
WERE. THAT HOW NOT A- AT THE
HIGHER LAW. AND WE'VE NEVER PULL
THAT BACK. SECOND AS DIRECTOR
JOHNSON MENTIONED THE STATE
COLLECTIVELY CAME TOGETHER AND
WITH THE AGREEMENT OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTOR SO SHE
STAKEHOLDERS CAME UP WITH THE
METHODOLOGY. THEY WOULD ADDRESS
BIG SWINGS IN INCREASE. OF A
CASELOAD AND DECREASES SO THIS
RAMP DOWN INCREMENTAL CHANGES
DIRECTED JOHNSON MENTIONED. AND
THEN THIRDLY HOMAGE. THERE'S NOT
A CLEAR FOR A DROP OFF IN
FUNDING. THE TWENTY ONE BUDGET
OUT THE STATE MADE A ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION- OR EXCUSE ME
AUGMENTED THE BASE FUNDING LEVEL
TO THAT METHODOLOGY WE AGREED TO
THREE YEARS AGO BY FORTY MILLION
ON GUN. WHICH ISN'T IS REFLECTED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGETS. AS
WELL AS A ONE TIME AUGMENTATION
ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT MILLION FOR
THIS CURRENT YEAR. SO I THINK
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IS INTO
IT WHEN WE'RE SHARING THIS
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE STATE NOT
PROVIDING ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR
HOURS ON END. WE ACTUALLY HAVE
BEEN AND THE WORKLOAD IS AN
APPEARANCE BECAUSE OUR CASELOAD
IS DOWN AND THAT'S THAT'S OUR
POSITION ON THAT SO. HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
BUT- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IT'S
CLARIFIED WE DON'T THINK THAT
THERE IS. A CLEAR FOR DROP OFF
OUR KIND OF FUND UNITS WITHIN.
THE AGREED UPON METHODOLOGY THE
STATE HAS. HAS DEVELOPED- I AM
HEARING YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO THOSE CONVERSATIONS I THINK
THE CONCERN WE HAVE IS AT THEIR
TIME OF NEED FOR CUTTING. THOSE
PROGRAMS AND THEIR ABILITY TO
HAVE THOSE CONNECTIONS THAT'S
HARMING THE PROGRAMS THAT. WE
NEED TO BE SUPPORTING RIGHT NOW
AND SO HOPEFULLY THAT'S NOT THE
CASE SINCE FOR YOUR- BUT WITH
THAT I WILL THANK THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES IN ASKED ET
ASKED TO COME FORWARD PLEASE.
I'M I'LL BEGIN IF I CAN WITH THE
PROMOTING WORK FOR STABILITY
PROPOSAL AND WE DIDN'T SEE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THUS FAR.
WITH THAT PROPOSAL AND I'M
HOPING TO. HEAR AN EXPLANATION
WHY AND- IF YOU PLAN TO INITIATE
THAT ROLL OUT IN THE BUDGET HERE
. THANK YOU CARLY CASSELLA
DEPARTMENT GLOBAL SERVICES SO-
WE DIDN'T INCLUDE FOR THE BILL
BUT WE ARE PLANNING TO LEVERAGE
EXISTING RESOURCES SO LOOKING AT
EXISTING TRAINING- LOOKING AT
OTHER PARTNERS TO PROVIDE
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM PRO SO LET
BUILDING ON WHAT EXISTS TODAY-
AND I'M SORRY FORGOT THE SECOND
. ARE YOU PLANNING ON INITIATING
A ROLLOUT YES THIS BUDGET YEAR
THANK YOU SECOND QUESTION DID
THE ADMINISTRATION CONSIDER THE-
RATE STUDY ACCELERATION FOR THE
MAY REVISION. AND CAN YOU
PROVIDE ANY FEEDBACK ON THE
PROPOSAL WHICH- STILL IS A
PRIORITY FOR MANY OF US MEMBERS
- ONLY CONFIRMING THAT IT'S NOT
IN THE MAYOR VISION BUT I THINK
SOME OF THE INITIAL FEEDBACK AND
DISCUSSIONS AS WE WERE ALL
LOOKING AT WAYS AND METHODS TO
ADDRESS THE- THE CURRENT AND
EMERGING WORKFORCE ISSUES. I
LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO RECTIFY THE
RATE STUDY WE COMPLETED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN- WITH THAT. I
WILL LOOK TO SEE IF ANY AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS- I
WILL PRIOR TO MOVING TOWARDS
PUBLIC COMMENT FOLLOW UP WITH.
THE S. S. AND ASK AS THEY
MENTIONED. TO CONVENE
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE ITEMS WE
SPOKE ABOUT TODAY IF POSSIBLE.
AND WITH THAT I WILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL OF OUR SPEAKERS
HERE TODAY. WE WILL NOW BEGIN
PUBLIC COMMENT. WE MAY HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND THEREFORE I WANT TO
URGE YOU. TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
BRIEF SO THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM
EVERYONE. WE WILL START WITH ANY
IN PERSON PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE
HEARING ROOM. PLEASE COME
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT.
RIGHT HERE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KATHY
SANDERLING MADONNA WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION FIRST JUST LET ME
THEY WERE REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
THE TIME THAT YOU SPENT THIS
YEAR WORKING WITH US AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT IS ALWAYS THE
NEEDS OF COUNTIES TO ADMINISTER
THE PROGRAMS AS YOU NOTED DIRECT
SERVICES INCLUDE THE SERVICES
THAT WE PROVIDE FOR OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE ELIGIBILITY STAFF
AND SO THINKING ABOUT IMPACTS ON
THOSE SERVICES ARE NOT FULLY
FUNDED IS REALLY CRITICAL TO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT TODAY. WE DO HAVE- JUST A
COUPLE AREAS OF CONCERN THE FLAG
I THINK YOU'VE ACTUALLY ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT BOTH OF THEM SO
FAR- FIRST WITH REGARDS TO OUR
ABILITY OPERATIONS IF ADOPTED AS
PROPOSED MAYOR VISION WHAT IS
UNITED CUT BOTH CALFRESH AND CAL
WORKS ELIGIBILITY OPERATIONS AT
A TIME WHEN THE CASES ARE
PROJECTED TO INCREASE AND BOTH
PROGRAMS AND HOW IT WORKS WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IS THAT THE
COUNTIES WOULD BE FORCED TO
SHIFT FUNDS FROM PLANET SERVICES
THIS IS WOULD COME AT A TIME AND
WE'RE BEING ASKED TO RE ENGAGE.
PEOPLE'S CLOCKS ARE TICKING
BECAUSE OF THE CHANGE TO THE-
THE NUMBER OF MONTHS THAT
THEY'RE AT THAT THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE WE- ARE ALSO SEEING
OPPORTUNITIES TO GET OUR CLIENTS
INTO JOBS THAT THEY MIGHT NOT
HAVE BEEN COMPETITIVE FOR IN THE
PAST THE PEOPLE ARE HIRING
THEY'RE PAYING WHILE THEY'RE
WILLING TO TRAIN BUT WE NEED TO
CONNECT THEM WITH THOSE JOBS AND
PROVIDING THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED IF THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO THAT
BECAUSE WE NEED TO KEEP THE
FRONT DOOR OPEN OR MANDATED TO
DO THIS ELIGIBILITY RELATED
SERVICES. WITH THE RESPECT TO
FINANCE WE ARE SPENDING THE
MONEY NOW THOSE COSTS ARE BEING
INCURRED BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE
WOULD NOT BE SPENDING THE MONEY
SO CUTTING IT WOULD BE A CUT TO
OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE SERVICES
IN CALFRESH I'M IN ADDITION TO
THE EXPEDITED SERVICES ISSUES
THAT DIRECTOR JOHNSON NOTED WE
ALSO HAVE BEEN SEEING INCREASED
TURN IN A HIGHER ERROR RATE
DURING THE PANDEMIC BOTH OF
THOSE THINGS WE THINK CAN BE
DIRECTLY CONTRIBUTED TO THE FACT
THAT WE'RE CONTINUING TO BE
FURTHER. AND FURTHER OUT. FROM
THE YEAR TWO. AND WHAT. AND THE
REASON I MENTION IS. THAT IS HOW
ARE. CURRENT STAFF ARE FUNDED.
BY THE STATE AS IF IT IS STILL
COSTING US. LIKE IT DID IN TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE WE'VE NOT
RECEIVED A COST OF DOING
BUSINESS INCREASE. FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS. THAT'S WHY WE'RE
DESPERATE FOR THAT REBASED
WORKER. WE UNDERSTAND AND
SUPPORT PUTTING IT OFF YOU DON'T
WANT TO DO A READ A STORY A
PENDANT IT'S A MESS. BUT IN THE
MEANTIME WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
AS A DOWN PAYMENT. THAT'S SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS THE METHOD. FOR
THE WERE. WE DO LOOK ABOUT WE'RE
OVER SPEND BY WE'LL- WOULD WHAT
WE WERE HAVE SEE. IF WE MORE.
COUNTIES ARE ALREADY SPENDING IT
NOW WE NEED THAT HELP TO BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE PROVIDING SERVICES.
AND TRY TO HELP STOP THE
HEMORRHAGING QUITE FRANKLY SO WE
CAN GET TO THAT NEW METHODOLOGY
. JUST QUICKLY ON THE TROUBLE
FOR AREA WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE PROPOSED INVESTMENTS AS YOU
HEARD FROM THE L. A. O. THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS NOT
OUT. WE DO- AS WE UNDERSTAND
SORT OF THE DESCRIPTION OF IN
PARTICULAR THE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. IT SOUNDS LIKE
IT WOULD BE- FOR SOMEWHAT NARROW
OF A SET OF SERVICES NOT AS
BROAD AS THE FLIPPERS SERVICES
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE
IN THE PAST. ALL KNOW THAT THE
REASON WHY COUNTIES RECEIVE HER
PURSE DURING THE CCR IS BECAUSE
WE HAVE NOT. ACTUALLY BEEN
REQUIRED TO DO THAT RECRUITMENT
AT THE TIME OF TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT- IT WAS NOT UNTIL C.
C. R. WITH AN ACTOR THAT THAT
BECAME A REQUIREMENT. LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IN PARTICULAR WAS
NOT DOING FOSTER PARENT
LICENSING UNTIL AFTER TWENTY
ELEVEN IT'S NOT IN OUR BASE WE
DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING FOR THAT.
SO WHAT WE'RE RECOMMENDING IS
THAT THE FUNDING BE PROVIDED
STATEWIDE AND WITHOUT A MATCH
AND TO BE PROVIDING THE SERVICES
THAT WE COULD DO THROUGH
PEPPERS. MORE TO COME OBVIOUSLY
IS THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
AND- GOES FORWARD WE LOOK
FORWARD IS ALWAYS TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. MISTER
JEREMIH CAROL WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY- THANK
YOU OF FIRST OF ALL FOR THE
ACTION YOU TOOK TODAY WHICH- IN
YOUR BUDGET THE LAST ITEM IN
YOUR- IN YOUR- ACTIONS TODAY WAS
TO ELIMINATE THE- THE PASS ON
FAMILY TO COUNTIES FOR OR- ANY
POTENTIAL PAN OF PENALTIES IN
THE FUTURE. THIS IS AN ACTION IS
LONG OVERDUE. AND FINALLY
REMOVES THIS BURDEN THAT'S BEEN
PLACED ON COUNTY SANTA
ULTIMATELY OUR CLIENTS. FOR
BEING SANCTIONED FOR BEING NOT
MEETING WORK RATES WE'RE TRYING
TO MOVE THIS PROGRAM FORWARD.
AND THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN A MAJOR
BARRIER IT'S TIME FOR US TO
THINK ABOUT THE FAMILIES AND
THEIR NEEDS AND NOT THE NEEDS
AND THE INTERESTS OF THE STATE
WHN IT COMES TO THESE
PENALTIES. O I JUST REALLY WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THAT ACTION
THAT YOU TOOK TODAY- WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE POWER STRIP
BY ELEVEN PERCENT. THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING THAT IS A
GOOD THING. BUT IT ALLS FRANKLY
FAR SHORT OF THE AGREEMENT THAT
WAS MADE FOUR YEARS AGO TO
INCREASE OUR TRANSIT. ASSISTANCE
ONE WHICH WOULD NOT KNOW CHARGE
NO FOR. IN THE STATE BUT HAVE A
CHILD LIVING IN DEEP POVERTY. WE
STILL NEED TO GET THERE. AND I'M
HOPING THAT THIS WILL BE THE
YEAR THAT WE DO IT IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET- ON S. ASIDE FROM
. WE ARE ASKING FOR THE SECOND
PART OF THE GRANT TO BE
XCELERATED TO JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE SO THE RECIPIENTS
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT AN ENTIRE
YEAR WE'RE VERY DISMAYED TO HEAR
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS. A
REDUCE THE SIZE OF THAT INCREASE
IN ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE A
CASELOAD INCREASE FOR YEARS WHEN
CASE THOSE WERE DECLINING NONE
OF THOSE GENERAL FUND SAVINGS
ARE EVER PASSED ALONG TO THE TO
THE RECIPIENTS IN THE FORMER
BRAND INCREASES BUT NOW THE
REVERSE IS HAPPENING THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING I THINK THE COMMITTEE
SHOULD TAKE A VERY CLOSE LOOK
AT- ON CHILD SUPPORT. AGAIN
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR A PASSING THROUGH
FORMALLY ASSISTED CASES BUT WE
STILL ARE ASKING THE COMMITTEE
TO PASS THROUGH ALL CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS TO THE CURRENT
POWERS CASES WHICH REPRESENT THE
POOREST CHILDREN IN OUR STATE
AND SO WE'RE HOPING AGAIN THAT
THE COMMITTEE WOULD BE ABLE TO
GET THAT INTO THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
AND I KNOW YOU'RE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME TO PROBABLY PATIENTS WITH
ME- OF- THE DEFENDANT. OKAY
THAT'S IT I I'M DONE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR ROMULAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S BECKY DEBBIE
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
ADULT DAY SERVICES REPRESENTING
TWO HUNDRED SEA BASS IN EIGHTY
P. CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA THE
BUDGET ASK THAT WE HAVE WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE MAY BUDGET
REVISION WE CONTINUE TO URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT OUR SIXTY ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR BRIDGE TO
RECOVERY ASKED THE PROPOSAL
MIRRORS A CHILD CARE FACILITY
IMPROVEMENT GRANT PROGRAM THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN FUNDED BY THE
STATE. AND IT ALSO DIRECTLY
PARALLELS SEVERAL GOALS IN THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO PROVIDE EQUITY AND
ACCESS TO CARE FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE FRAIL AND DISABLED.
FINDING IS ALSO IMPERATIVE FOR
CENTERS TO PROVIDE A TRACE SAFE
TRANSITION FOR BACK TO IN CENTER
SERVICES IN ADDRESSES COVERT
RESPONSE BY HELPING CENTERS MAKE
NECESSARY FACILITY IMPROVEMENTS.
EASES WORKFORCE ISSUES AND VERY
HARD TRANSPORTATION ISSUES AGAIN
IT KEEPS THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION SAFE AND OUT OF
NURSING HOMES OVER FORTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS RELY ON
OUR SERVICES. THERE IS ALSO A
LITTLE BIT OF AN URGENCY RIGHT
NOW POTENTIALLY JULY FIRST THERE
IS AN END TO THE TEMPORARY
ALTERNATIVE SERVICES THAT HAVE
BEEN AUTHORIZED AND SENTENCE
MUST RE OPEN FULLY AT THE END OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. I
THIS FUNDING IS NOT APPROVED
CENTERS MAY NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO STAY OPEN
IT'S CRITICAL BECAUSE WITHOUT
THIS FUNDING CENTERS WILL CLOSE
AND CLIENTS WILL LOSE THE
NECESSARY SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THEY NEED. MAY RETURN TO NURSING
HOMES OR MAY NOT BE ABLE TO STAY
IN SERVICE ALSO I JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT MOST OF THE FUNDING
REQUEST. THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE
AND THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS
BEING FINALIZED IS AGAIN EXEMPT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
THE DUCHESS YES. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DANIEL
CONFESSING ON THE PUBLIC POLICY
MANAGER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS AND I WANT TO-
APPLY TO ONE OF THE- BUDGET-
ITEMS HERE IT IS SPECIFICALLY
ITEM KNOWN ISSUE TWENTY NINE-
THIS IS THE- COMMUNITY LIVING
FUND TEN MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
INVESTMENT TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION. TO
EXPAND SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
THAT ASSIST OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
TRANSITIONING FROM NURSING HOMES
TO- AND INTENT LIVING COMMUNITY
- WE WANT TO- EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL I ALSO
HAVE SOME COMMENTS FROM SOME OF
OUR- A SIMILAR CONSUMERS HERE
THAT REALLY COULD BENEFIT FROM
THIS- WHAT THIS- FUNDING MEANS
FOR THE COMMUNITY LIVING-
INVESTMENT. MEANS MORE
TRANSITION SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND WITH
DISABILITIES THAT WANT TO LIVE
IN THEIR COMMUNITY AND JUST NEED
A LITTLE EXTRA SUPPORT TO MAKE
IT HAPPEN. THAT ALSO MEANS
CONNECTING PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY WITH
DISABLED- ROLE MODELS WHO CAN
PROVIDE THE CENTRAL PEER
SUPPORT. AT TO BE SUCCESSFUL
AMIN'S INSURING THAT THOS ARE
OFTEN UNABLE TO RETURN TO THEIR
HOMES AFTER A STROKE OR OTHER
EXPECTED MEDICAL EMERGENCY- HAVE
THE FUND UNIVERSES OF TECHNOLOGY
OR OTHER DISABILITIES EQUIPMENT
NEEDED TO LIVE AND THRIVE SAFELY
IN THEIR OWN HOMES SO I THINK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND- URGE
STRONG CONSIDERATION FOR THE
SUB. PROPOSAL THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
MR CHEN MEMBERS CHRIS RESPONSES.
POLICY ADVOCATE THE WESTERN AND
I'M ON POVERTY- OUR FIRST RECORD
THE LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT THE
FOOD FOOD FOR A PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD EXTEND. C. FIVE BENEFITS
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS OR THE
RANGE. ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD OUR
ORGANIZATION STANDS FIRMLY
AGAINST POLICIES. THAT LEADS
FAMILIES TO DO FAMILY SEPARATION
WHEN FAMILIES ARE REFERRED TO
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. TODAY
WE'RE ASKING THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE MONEY FOR EXPERIENCE
NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN PROVIDE
PRE PETITION LEGAL SERVICES TO
THESE FAMILIES. PROCESS IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO STOP REFRAIN.
FROM THE REFERRING OF COWARDS
FAMILIES THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM DUE TO FINANCIAL EXACT
INSTEAD THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
PROVIDE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE THE
FAMILIES. OF THE FAMILIES
TELEVISION STABILIZATION
PROGRAM. OF THE LEGISLATURE IS
UNABLE ALLOCATE FUNDING FOR
THESE TWO ITEMS THIS YEAR. GOOD
ACTORS ARE THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE REPORT NEXT FOR NEXT
YEAR'S BUDGET. OUGHT. TO
CONSIDER THESE TWO ITEMS THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMY
WESTLING AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES ARE GONNA
SUBMITTED A COMPREHENSIVE BUDGET
RESPONSE LETTER- I BELIEVE OVER
THE WEEKEND ADD TO MEMBERS AND
STAFF AND JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
AND FOREMOST WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
RELATED TO WORK FORCE WE DON'T
VIEW THIS AS AN EITHER OR
PROPOSAL- INVESTING IN WORKFORCE
NEEDS TO HAPPEN ALL OVER THE
PLACE AND IT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN
OUR SYSTEM IN A VARIETY OF WAYS.
SO THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
BRINGS PEOPLE INTO THE FRONT
DOOR HEARD ENHANCES RETENTION
AND- IT ALSO DOES THE SAME ON
THE REGIONAL CENTER STAFF SIDE
BUT WE KNOW THAT A LONGER TERM
SOLUTION IS ADDRESSING THE STAFF
SALARIES THAT ARE BE BETTER ABLE
TO BE PAID LONG TERM AND THAT
INVOLVES FUNDAMENTALLY UPDATING
THE REGIONAL CENTER CORE
STAFFING FORMULA AS WELL AS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE RATE
MODELS. SECOND WE APPLAUD THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
RELATED TO EARLY START IN THE
EXPANSION OF THAT PROGRAM IT'S
CRITICAL TO GET AS MANY CHILDREN
WHO ARE AT RISK OF DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAY IN DISABILITY INTO THE
PROGRAM AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ADDRESS- THE PROVIDER CAPACITY
IN THIS AREA AND TO WORK
TOGETHER TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
EXPAND TO ENSURE WE HAVE ENOUGH
PROVIDERS TO SERVE THE NEW
CHILDREN THAT ARE ENTERING. AND
THIRD WE APPLAUD THE ATTENTION
BEING PAID TO THE FAMILY FEES
THE ANNUAL FAMILY PROGRAM P. AND
THE FAMILY COST PARTICIPATION
PROGRAM. BUT CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE STRONGLY FOR THE TOTAL
ELIMINATION OF THESE PROGRAMS
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEN LEWIS
REPRESENTING US YOU'RE NOT ONE
OF THE FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES IN
THE STATE I WANTED TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT ON. SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS AROUND FAMILY FINDING
AND IT'S YOUR T. P. TRANSITION
DOLLARS AND WHAT HAD HOPED WE'D
SEEN FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
SOME ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT IN THE COVERED RELIEF
REST OUR TEE PEES. WE KNOW THAT
THE REQUEST THAT CAME AND REALLY
IT FAR OUTSTRIPPED THE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES THAT WERE AVAILABLE
UNDER YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND WE HOPE THAT
THROUGH THAT BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS
YOU CAN TO PUT SOME ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
GET AROUND 32% OF OUR REQUESTED
FUNDS- THAT WE HAVE PLAYED FOR.
THEN SWITCHING HATS FOR THE
MORE- CHILDREN NOW FOR THE
EMERGENCY CHALKER BRIDGE PROGRAM
AND WE APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS THAT WERE INCLUDED FOR
KENNY ADMINISTRATION OF THE
PROGRAM AND HOPE THAT SHE WOULD
SUPPORT THE ADVOCATES PROPOSAL
TO SEE MORE DOLLARS FOR TRAINING
NAVIGATIONS AND VOUCHER DOLLARS.
FOR OUR CHILDREN THAT COME IN AT
DIFFERENT TIMES THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR THOSE DOLLARS CAN DRAW DOWN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS WHICH
WE THINK IS A REALLY A KEY POINT
OF THE PROPOSAL AND IT'S BEEN
BAKED IN AROUND FOR AWHILE AND
READY TO GO SO. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TIME. THANK YOU. WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AS A REMINDER
THE PHONE NUMBER AND THE
PASSCODE IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING OVER
THE INTERNET THE NUMBER AGAIN IS
TOLL FREE. 877-692-8957 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU OPERATOR WE ARE READY TO
BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OUR FIRST COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR
ARAMBULA AND UNITY MEMBERS
NICOLE BORNEMANN ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
EXPANSION OF THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. CALIFORNIANS
AGE FIFTY FIVE AND OLDER AS WELL
AS REQUEST FURTHER EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM TO ALL AGES. WE APPLAUD
THE GOVERNOR FOR EXPANDING
FEEDBACK TO ENSURE THAT
IMMIGRANTS OVER FIFTY FIVE CAN
ACCESS COULD BENEFIT. HOWEVER IT
IS VITAL THAT CHILDREN USE ALSO
BE ABLE TO ACCESS THESE BENEFITS
BECAUSE OF THE DETRIMENTAL
IMPACT THAT FOOD INSECURITY HAS
ON CHILD HEALTH AND DEVELOPMENT
INCLUDING CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS. EDUCATIONAL THE
LATEST COGNITIVE AND BEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS AND MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES. THEREFORE WE ARE
REQUESTING AN EQUITABLE FOOD
SAFETY NET FOR CALIFORNIANS OF
ALL AGES BUT THAT'S NOT
DISCRIMINATE ON THE BASIS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU RIDE NINE PRESCHOOL I HAD.
HI THIS IS JUSTIN CARE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ATHLETES ACTIVE
GRATEFUL FOR TWO NEW FOSTER CARE
INVESTMENTS REVISE THE FIFTY
MILLION FOR RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL IN THE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR INSTANCE THE FAMILY
FINDING OUT BUT WE WOULDN'T
ALLOW THE SPENDING IS WELCOME TO
MEET THE CRITICAL NEED ACID FACT
THAT SUPPORT THE REQUEST FROM C.
TO B. D. A. TO INSTEAD USE THIS
AMOUNT TO PROVIDE A HUNDRED
MILLION ONGOING. UNFUNDED COUNTY
ARE A WORKLOAD THAT THE STATE IS
REQUIRED TO COVER UNDER
PROPOSITION THIRTY AND HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE THIRD PERSON
PROGRAM TO HELP ENSURE THAT ALL
COUNTIES IS THE FAMILY PLANNING
FUNDING AND IT'S IN A TIMELY
MANNER INSTEAD OF UTILIZING THE
PROPOSED GRANT PROGRAMS. WITH
COUNTY MATCH. REGARDING UPDATING
COUNTY ADMINS. PLENTY AT THE
FACT THAT FOR IT. SOUNDS ABOVE
THE MAIN RIVAS. FOR CALIBRATION
TO THE NEW BUDGETING
METHODOLOGIES DEVELOPED THE
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTY MILLION
ANNUALLY. WHICH IS CRITICALLY
NEEDED TO HELP INDIVIDUALS
ACCESS ACCESS IS IMPORTANT
NUTRITION BENEFITS. AND IT BURKE
OUR TO SUPPORT A FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR BACK FILL FOR THE
PROPOSED CUTS TO COUNTY
ELIGIBILITY OPERATIONS WHICH
WILL HELP PREVENT COUNTY TO
SHIFT RESOURCES AWAY. WOMEN OF
FAMILY SEEKTO RE ENGAGE IN A
WORK FORCE. AFFINE PROVIDE THAT
FACT THAT PROVIDERS PROPOSAL
FEEDBACK APPRECIATE THE
TRANSITION FUNDING AND EXPENSE
START DATE WHICH WILL HELP
COUNTY SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT
THIS PROGRAM WE LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER ENGAGEMENT ON THESE AND
OTHER ISSUES. THANK YOU OPERATOR
CAN WE GO TO THE NEXT CALLER AND
BRIEFLY WILL JUST STATE I
BELIEVE WE HAVE TWENTY CALLERS
WHO ARE CURRENTLY- WAITING TO
PROVIDE. FIFTY COLORS EXCUSE ME
WHO ARE WAITING TO PROVIDE.
PUBLIC COMMENT AND WOULD ASK
THOSE COLORS TO PLEASE SPEAK UP
IF YOU CAN SO WE CAN HEAR YOU
HEAR IN THE HEARING ROOM. YOUR
MIND TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON A DOCTOR
REGULATE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO JORDAN LANDING WITH
THE ARGUMENTS REPORT IN
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION- FIRST
WE WANT TO FOR SOMEONE TO COME
IT'S REPRESENTING THE LADERMAN
COALITION- WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS IN THE
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS OUR
WORKFORCE CRISIS IN THE BUBBLE
SERVICES- WE DO HOWEVER BELIEVE
THAT. FOR STATE THAT ME. WELL
GOOD ARE NOT COOPER. AND INSTEAD
WE OF COURSE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL PUT FORWARD TO
ACCELERATE THE RATE STUDY
IMPLEMENTATION WHICH WILL
HOPEFULLY PROVIDE A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE OF WAGE
INCREASES FOR THE WORK FORCE AS
WELL TO PROVIDE STABILITY MOVING
FORWARD AS WE COME OUT OF THE
PEOPLE THAT MAKE. AND WILL
CRUMBLE NOT A PORT PORTS WE HAVE
LOST DURING THAT TIME- DOCTOR
AND WE THANK YOU FOR THOSE
EFFORTS WE ALSO OF COURSE
SUPPORT THE- LATER CALLED. THE
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF SERVICE COORDINATORS OF
REGIONAL CENTERS BY TAKING CORE
STAFFING FORMULA. AND THANK THE
LEGISLATORS SUBCOMMITTEE WHO ARE
WORKING TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND
WE HOPE THAT WE COULD IN THE
FINAL PROPOSAL. ON BEHALF OF THE
HARKING ADDED THREE WILL THE
ALSO WANTS. BUT IT'S A.
APPLICABLE TO EXPAND ELIGIBLE
CURLY SERVER. CRITICAL IN TO GET
THOSE- SO BEGAN SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED TO LIMIT
HAVE THE BILL- WE OPPOSED RESULT
. OF THE ON. STARTING JAN FOR-
THOSE TO WE HAVE HAD THEM FOR
THE PAST YEARS AND OUR DENTAL
FUND HAS BEEN. JEFF FINE WITH
THE- STARTING PRECLUDE NOT THE
TIME TO START IMPOSING THE FEET
AGAIN ON FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS. WITH ABOUT
POSSIBILITIES. WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL TO EXCEL THE SCIENTIFIC
SPEAK. AND SO INDUSTRIES REPORT
TO CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM FOR
GREATER UTILIZATION OF
TECHNOLOGY DELIVERING SUPPORT
SERVICES AND OF COURSE JUST- I
THINK THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
STAFF FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
EFFORTS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
. THANK YOU RYAN THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JOSH
DUGGAR ON BEHALF OF LOCAL
CLIENTS TODAY FOCUSED ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES HIS
PERSONA GOT THAT THE STATE
INNOVATION AND STRATEGY TO
EMPOWER PEOPLE WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE FIVE MILLION
THE TDF PILOT PROGRAM OF THE
PORT. WE HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING
FOR A SIMILAR PILOT THAT CAN
PROMOTE SUPPORTED TECHNOLOGY
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE
INCLUSIVE AN INDEPENDENT LIFE
FOR PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. I
DIDN'T WITH THE ADMIN. AND THE
LAST TO POLIO OUR COLLECTIVE.
BACK IN ON BEHALF THE- COMMUNITY
LIVING NETWORK WE ARE SUPPORTED
BUT THE EXPEDIA COMPLAINT BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND ENCOURAGE
MAKING THAT INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC UPON
RECEIPT. THE BILL AND IT ALSO
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PDF ME
REVISION PROPOSAL FOR A
WORKFORCE STABILITY PACKAGE
AIMED AT ADDRESSING RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION OF DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL. INCLUDING THE MOST
SUPPORT PILOT. CURRENT IN A WAY
THAT FUNDING TO THE PROVIDE AND
EMPLOYEES AT QUICKLY IF THANK
YOU FOR. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR I'M GLAD
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LINDA CHORALE AND I'M CALLING
FROM SAN JOAQUIN COLLEGE OF LAW
AND THE NEW AMERICAN LEGAL
CLINIC HERE IN FRESNO CLOVIS
CALIFORNIA. AND I'M CALLING IN
REGARDS TO THE FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM AND ASK THE DOCTOR OF
THE CLINIC I'VE WORKED IN THE
FIELD OF IMMIGRATION LAW FOR
OVER A DECADE NOW. WE'VE
PROVIDED QUALITY PRO BONO LEGAL
SERVICES AND PROVIDE A
SUSTAINABLE PIPELINE IF
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEYS THROUGH
THE DEVELOPMENT AND MENTORSHIP
OF LAW STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE
PAST TEN. YOU SEEN ANY PATIENT
ATTORNEY SO DIRE. THE MODEL OF
THE FELLOWSHIP ALLOWS FOR NEW
ATTORNEYS TO BE HOUSED IN RURAL
REGIONS WHILE BEING TRAINED IN A
COLLABORATIVE STRUCTURE. BUY THE
BEST MENTORS INTERSTATE AND IT
PROVIDES A COLLABORATIVE
SOLUTION TO THE CHALLENGE OF
BUILDING CAPACITY AND IT'S A
REASONABLE INVESTMENT NOT ONLY
IN OUR LOCK GRADUATE BUT OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND IN PROTECTING
DUE PROCESS. SIX FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET WOULD ONLY ALLOW
FOR OUR CURRENT COHORT OF
FELLOWS TO COMPLETE THEIR
PROGRAM. BUT IF THE FALL
EXTREMELY SHORT EXPANDING NEW
REGIONS OF NEW COHORT. AND
CLINICS TAKE MINE. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE DEVELOP THE
LEGAL CAPACITY IN THE MOST
VULNERABLE REGIONS OF OUR STATE
WHILE WE HAVE THE TIME AND THE
RESOURCES TO DETAIL. GIVEN THE
CONSTANTLY SHIFTNG LANDSCAPE AS
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT. AND
MAKE SURE GREAT FREDDIE IN. OF
THE K. EMIGRATE LEGAL FELLOWSHIP
INTIMATE REVISION BUDGET BUT I
REALLY ASK FOR YOU TO CONSIDER
EXPANDING THAT AMOUNT TO THE TEN
MILLION THAT'S REQUIRED TO
SUSTAIN AND BUILD THIS PROGRAM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MARTI AMADO FAMILY MEMBER OF
A SISTER WHO HAD DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND EXTENDED FAMILY
MEMBER OF THE TWENTY NINE YEAR
OLD YOUNG MAN WITH DOWN SYNDROME
WHO LIVES WITH ME I'M AND UNPAID
CARE GIVER AND ALSO WHICH YOU
CAN CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SENIOR
COMMUNITY ACTION NETWORK- ****
MONOCLE MY SUPPORT- FOR THAT
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY COMMENTS. ESPECIALLY
THOSE RELATED TO S. R. P. THE
PORT THE GOVERNOR'S- MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND ON
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S UP
MAY REVISION ON THE EXPANSION OF
EARLY START ELIGIBILITY- BUT
WOULD ADD THAT WE WOULD URGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE. AND
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT IN THE
COLDEST MAKE SURE THAT REMOTE
SERVICES FOR EARLY START
FAMILIES ARE STILL OFFERED
BEYOND JUNE. MANY TWENTY TWO.
AND ALSO THAT THERE IS AN OUT
AND LETTING BE KNOW ABOUT THIS.
IS REALLY- NUMBER THREE AND
FINALLY- HELLO I MEAN ACTUALLY-
NUMBER THREE- SUPPORT DEPARTMENT
SUSPENSION OF PARENTAL PETE WE
THINK THAT REALLY NEEDS TO BE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE WORLD WE
APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT- IT'S
AN EXTENDING THE- WAIVER OF.
FEES AND TELL THE END OF THIS
YEAR BUT NEED TO BE PERMANENT
AND LASTLY ON THE WORK FORCE-
STABILITY PROPOSAL SUPPORTED
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSALS BUT
WOULD AGREE WITH THE L. A- THAT
THERE NEED TO BE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE HE OUTLINED
IMPLEMENTATION. AND OTHER. AND
LASTLY. APPRECIATE MR RAMBLER
KNOW YOU RAISING THE ISSUE OF
THE RATE STUDY. AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE ACCELERATION OF THE
RATE STEADY AS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF WORKFORCE. AND WHEN
I THINK THE SUBCOMMITTEE- THE
STAFF AND ALSO THE MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE- THE WAY YOU
CONDUCT NEED HEARINGS IN THE WAY
THAT YOU'RE REALLY EMPHASIZING
THE NEED FOR PERSON CENTERED.
OUTCOMES. WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO
MY FAMILY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
RYAN TWENTY NINE PEOPLE HAVE. A
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THIRD EYE
BLIND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS NOT ACCEPTED ON POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE NY STATE GOING
TO CANNOT COMMUNITY ORGANIZING
PROJECTS IN THE CALIFORNIA
CENTER CLOSE. WE WANT TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS BUDGET
PLAN- AN ALLOCATION OF THE FAT
NUTRITION BENEFITS FOR
IMMIGRANTS FIFTY FIVE AND OVER
BUT HIS MAY REVISION MISSED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO FOOD
ASSISTANCE WE SUPPORT FOOTBALL
BECAUSE THAT WILL MITIGATE
HUNGER AND POVERTY BY ENSURING
THEIR SIGNATURE SYSTEMS NOT MADE
ON THE BASIS THE MIGRATION. WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO PART WITH
FOR ALL AND EXPAND CALIFORNIA
COULD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
BENEFITS CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
AGES REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
VERY THIRTY FIVE. PLEASE GO AYE.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR ON JULY
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO BECOME
ARKANSAS ON BEHALF OF LEADING H.
CALIFORNIAN LIFESTYLE EXPERT
ACCUSED HIM OF THE
ADMINISTRATION SPENDING PROPOSAL
CDA FOUR MILLION FOR EXPEDIA AND
FOURTEEN POINT NINE MILLION FOR
THE CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE WE SUPPORT
YOU PROPOSALS WHICH ADDRESS
CONTAINED IN BUDGET ACCENT
ASSEMBLY BILL AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HYSTERIA. THE
FIRST OF THE TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SEVEN WHICH SHOULD PROVIDE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH A HOUSING
SUBSIDY GETS THE GATE FOR ALL
ACCEDI A FOR OLDER ADULTS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES ARE.
OR AT RISK OF HOW MUCH SH AND A
TWENTY FIVE FORTY ACT FIVE OR
DOLLARS. OVER FIVE YEARS WHICH
WOULD. THE HELP YOUR EACH PLACE
YOUR SKIN KERR TBH DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE IS GOING HEALTHCARE
SOCIAL SERVICES AND AFFORDABLE
SENIOR HOUSING SITE WHICH
ENABLING OLDER RESIDENTS TO
REMAIN LIVING INDEPENDENTLY AND
AVOIDING UNNECESSARY AND COSTLY
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. SUCH AS
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY FACE. WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO FUND MEETS
YOUR PRIORITIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU KNOWCALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU I'M THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT AFTER GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS CAPTAIN OFFERED
SPEAKING ON BEHALF THREE CLIENTS
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS WEEK WELL WE APPRECIATE
THE FIFTY MILLION PROPOSED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S JAN TEN BUDGET
FOR CAL FOODS WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT NO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WAS PROPOSED
IN THE BAY REVISED. TWENTY
MILLION TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE%
BUDGET FOR CALHOUN TO REFLECT
SITUATION THAT PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
MAY. CURRENTLY 20% OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL GROUP TO
THE TEACHER AND AN INCREASE IN
JANUARY- BANKS EVERYTHING LEFT
FEDERAL SUPPORTING CALFRESH
RECIPIENTS WILL BE LOOKING AT
LOSING EMERGENCY ALLOTMENTS ONCE
THE TRACKS. FEDERAL PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND- WE ARE
ALSO SEEING HUGE INCREASES IN
FOOD COSTS. I REQUEST FOR
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION FOR
CALHOUN IN THE MIND OF THE STATE
SUPPORT THAT PROVIDED LAST YEAR
AND GIVEN THE CRISIS OUR FOOD
BANKS ARE FACING STILL. WE HOPE.
THAT THE TO BE PRIORITIZED WE'RE
ALSO ASKING THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE A HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION
ONE TIME FOR CALAMITY PASSED THE
ENHANCEMENT. AS WELL AS MAKE
THAT SEEKS OUT. PERMANENT THESE
WERE NOT INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE. THAT ARE
CRITICALLY NEEDED TO MAKE SURE.
THE CORE TO THE COMMUNITY WE
SERVE HOW WE CERTAINLY TO ON TO
THE SUPPORT FOR FOOD ALL- AND
THEN I'LL BE HOW. OF THE
CALIFORNIA SO SHE- REJECTED THAT
EACH. WE WERE JUST THE IN THE OF
TO BE. ABOUT FOR CAL. IN THE MAY
RIVER. WITH THEM. SUPPORT THE
FUNDS IN A RAPIDLY GROWING OLDER
POPULATION THAT IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY BEEN IMPACTED
BY THE- EPIDEMIC. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT THE- THIS IS THE
LEVEL SERVICE PROVIDED TO WHO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT VULNERABLE
OLDER CALIFORNIA THE FOR
FUNCTIONS. WHEN THE CURRENT
FEDERAL STIMULUS IS GONE
MILLIONS OF OLDER CALIFORNIANS
WILL FACE IF. SHOULD BE REMOVED
FROM PROGRAMS FOR WHICH THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE DESPERATELY NEED
ADDITIONALLY AS THE STATE MOVES
TOWARD A QUARTER OF THE
POPULATION BEING OVER THE AGE OF
SIXTY BE GEIGER. HOW THE
SERVICES OR THE INFRASTRUCTURE
TO SUPPORT. THE SHEER NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUAL TO BE. WE URGE YOU TO
MAKE THE- AND THOSE IN. HAVE A
LOT WITH THE SUPPORT THE GOALS
OF THE AFTER PLAY TO INCLUDE.
ADDITIONAL SEVENTY MILLION. TO
EXPAND THE STATE'S CORNMEAL
CAPACITY FOR SENIOR. NINETY
MILLION FOR COMMUNITY BASED
SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS WERE CUT
IN AND OUT IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
TENET HAVEN'T BEEN RESTORED.
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION TO
ESTABLISH A PILOT PROGRAM TO
FIND THE FAMILY IN CARE GIVER
SUPPORT PROGRAM- FOR THOSE WITH
ALZHEIMER'S AND RELATED
DEMENTIA. THIRTY THREE MILLION
TO SUPPORT AGING IN PLACE
RESOURCES THE FUNDS. WOULD
SUPPORT A NAVIGATOR. ATTENTION
SENIOR HOUSE AND HOME. AND THEN
THIRTEEN MILLION TO SUPPORT
VOLUNTEER RECRUITMENT IN
COORDINATION ALL INSURANCE THAT
IS UP IT'S A CONSENSUAL MR
BECAUSE WE PROVIDE AND WITHOUT
SUPPORT RIVER SPEAKING SHE BONTA
POPULATION. AND LASTLY ON BEHALF
OF. THE WILL CALIFORNIA WANT TO
SHARE THEIR SUPPORT FOR ALL THE
PROGRAMS PUT FORWARD BY THE AREA
AGENCIES WITH A STRONG CALL OUT
OF SUPPORT FOR THAT MUCH NEEDED. NUTRITION DOLLARS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. NEXT IS.
THANK NEXT YEAR RIGHT FORTY.
THANK YOU RIGHT FORTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO IN THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TEACHER DRESS
THE COMMITTEE CHAIR I AM
RETURNING TO BRING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF THE BLIND
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS. AND ON BEHALF OF THAT I
WOULD LIKE THE FIRST STAGE THE
COMMITTEE FOR- THAT
CONSIDERATION OF. A PILOT
PROGRAM TO ASSESS VISUAL
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE LOSING THEIR
VISION VISION REHABILITATION
SERVICES WHEN THEY ARE ABLE TO
GO BACK TO WORK BECAUSE OF AGE
OR THEIR DISABILITIES AND SO
THAT IS AMAZING AS WELL AS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO. CAN THAT
WITH WAYS TO HELP COMMUNITY
LIVING WHERE PEOPLE CAN STAY OUT
OF NURSING HOMES I ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE IN
. SPECIALLY THE SENATE FOR
PROPOSING THAT WE HAVE A ONE
TIME EXPENDITURE TO. BEASTIE AT
THAT SITE BENEFIT TO RESTORE
FUNDS AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
EITHER RESTORATION FUNDS THEY
ARE NOT AN INCREASE AS IN A
NORMAL INCREASE BUT PLANS WERE
REBUILT ELEVEN YEARS AGO BECAUSE
OF THE DEFICIT AND IT SEEMS
FITTING THAT NOW THAT WE HAVE A
SURPLUS THAT THIS POPULATION
WOULD BE ADDRESSED AS WELL AS
THE GOLD STATE STIMULUS THIS IS
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE AND EVEN
THOUGH IT ONCE AGAIN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR. WE NEED. REMEMBER THIS
POP THANK YOU VERY THANK YOU
OPERATE WE ARE GOING TO PAUSE ON
PUBLIC COMMENT IF I CAN SO THAT
I MAY OPEN THE ROLE- FOR CHAIR
TEAM WHO IS HERE- AND JUST SO
WE'RE ALL FOLLOWING AT HOME WE
ARE GOING TO COLLAPSE THE THREE
HEALTH POSTS THAT WE DID IN TWO
ONE. CURRENTLY WE ARE VOTED ON
ITEMS ONE THROUGH EIGHTY FOUR ON
HEALTH WILL OPEN THAT ROLE FOR
CHAIR TEMP. MISTER CHANG CHENG
ARE. TAKING ON. WE WILL NOW OPEN
THE ROLE FOR THE HUMAN SERVICES
ITEMS ONE THROUGH FIFTY FIVE.
TANG HAI TINA. THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW RETURN BACK TO PUBLIC
COMMENT OPERATOR CAN WE HAVE THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YOUR MIND
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
FORTY FOUR OF WHAT IS. I WANTED
BECAUSE I AM TODAY WE SUPPORT
THE CONTINUED FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MASTER
PLAN OF AGING ARE SUPPORT FOR
THE AGES THAT MINIMUM WAGE
ADJUSTMENTS WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUE DISCUSSION
FOR DIRECTOR JOHNSON AND HER
TEAM ABOUT THE EACH OF THE
PROMINENT. PROVIDER BACKED UP
THE- MISS WHY AND WE'RE HAVING A
HARD TIME HEARING YOU WE LOST
ABOUT THE LAST FIFTEEN SECONDS.
I WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE WOULD
NOT BE GOOD. FIVE FOR THE FULL.
MISS WHITE WE'RE HAVING A REAL
DIFFICULT RECEIVING YOUR
TESTIMONY I MAY ASK YOU TO CALL
BACK- MORE PROVIDE IT IN WRITTEN
FORMAT WERE HAPPY TO RECEIVE IT-
BUT WITH THAT OPERATOR IF WE CAN
HAVE THE NAME. PLEASE YOUR MIND
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON BOUNCE AROUND THE
LAND AND THE REST OF THE
COMMUNITY JACKIE GONZALEZ I
DON'T THINK THE FANS. I'M
WRITING ANTHONY CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRATION LEGAL FELLOWSHIP
WE'D LIKE TO THANK. THE
MINISTRATIONS CARE THINKING
DOCUMENT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AT
THE CHAIR NOTE HOWEVER. ADVOCATE
FOR PUBLIC FIGURES HE SHOULD.
THE REQUESTED THAT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN MARCH PART AND YOU
CAN BE GOOD LIKE BE ABLE TO. THE
CURRENT CODE. COMPLETE THEIR
TENURE. NISHI A NEW BALLOTS WITH
UNDERSTATEMENT WORLD FROM STATE. WE APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR ON A-
IN THE WINTER SEVENTY FIVE
DOLLARS AFTER BORDER WE WRECKED
. ALSO ADVOCATE OUT WHATEVER
HAVE DAUGHTER. ON IMMIGRATION IN
. THE ENTIRE THING OF PUBLIC. ON
THE FIFTY THE COMMUNITY BUT OF
THESE PEOPLE WERE EVENT CALL
HOME AND THOSE ARE THE THREE
BILLION REGIONS LIKE THE CONTROL
VALLEY IN THE COUNTRY COAST. SO
WE WILL COME ASK THE LEGISLATURE
- YOU CAN THAT THINK IT'S GOING
BE MOUNT. HOLLY IN ORDER TO GET
WITH COMMON THE ALREADY THE WE
CAN TALK WELCOME IT CAN BE THREE
D. AND. I THOUGHT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALL PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN
FIFTY PLEASE AT. THANK YOU WHAT
. FROM OF OUR LEADERS THE
GROCERY. BUT OF A BLACK
COMMITTEE I'M ALSO ABOUT OF
ISSUE THROUGH EIGHTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTED TO LEVEL.
PROGRAM IN LED BY COLLEGE THE
PIECES OF THE I'M ALSO REQUEST
ADDRESS OF TO INCREASE THE A TO
ONE WE ACTUALLY REQUEST WHICH IS
TEN YEARS IN. THERE ARE TWO
CONTRIBUTE DEVELOP THE
REGISTRATION OKAY THINK OF
CENTRAL IN THE COAST TO CIRCULAR
ECONOMIES RECITING.
BEFORE LOS WE WANT TO FINISH.
THIRD YEAR WITH THE KERN FELLOW
AND ALSO RECRUIT TRAIN AND
DEPLOY A SECOND COHORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND DR NUMBER.
IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES STUDENTS TO
REJOICE AND WEEP THANK YOU FOR.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDED BUT WE
FIGURE FOR EVERY. THANK NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. COPYRIGHT
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR BELIEF I
AM WITH THE IDEA MAGIC WORKERS
ASKED ME LOOK AT THIRTY NINE
THIRTY CARPETING OVER A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND I H.
THAT AND CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
ACROSS THE STATE WHAT TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR ISSUE OUR ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY TWO THE ISIS
MINIMUM WAGE JEFF SMITH WERE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE ON GOING
FUNDING TO ESTABLISH A PERMANENT
ACCESS BACKED UP BY THE SYSTEM
IN THE ADDITIONAL EXEMPTION TO
THE EIGHTY HOUR LIMIT. WE DO
WANT TO EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION
TO ISSUE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY FOUR
THE PROPOSAL I JUST THAT SIMPLY
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WOULD
REPEAL NUMEROUS LONG STANDING
PRECEDENT UNDER WHICH PUBLIC
ENTITY THAT FUND AND ADMINISTER
THE ACCESS PROGRAM ARE
RECOGNIZED AS JOINT EMPLOYERS OF
THE PROVIDERS UNDER EXISTING
STATUTES THE CHANGE WOULD BE
DETRIMENTAL TO THE PROGRAM AS A
WHOLE AND WHY WE ARE CLOSE
LASTLY LIKE TO LISTEN REQUEST
SUPPORT FOR THE FOLLOWING THE
PUBLIC THAT WERE NOT IN THE MAY
REVISION. THAT'S WHAT IT AFTER
RELIEF PROPOSAL JOINTLY WITH AT
YEAH YOU AND P. W. D. A. WHAT
WOULD PROVIDE AMONG OTHER
PROVISIONS A TWO DOLLAR WAGE
DIFFERENTIAL FOR ISIS PROVIDERS
CARING FOR RECIPIENTS DURING
EMERGENCIES WE ALSO PROPOSE
CLOSING THE GAP IN UNION ACT
THAT THE NEW EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATION BY REQUIRING A
RETURNS ON SITE IN IN PERSON
ORIENTATIONS THAT PROVE THE
CALPERS PROGRAM PRICE THAT
MATTERS TOGETHER WITH THAT YEAH
YOU WHERE PROPOSED THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION TO ALLOW PROVIDERS
TO AUTOMATICALLY DEDUCT PEOPLE.
AT CONTRIBUTIONS TO CALPERS
FINALLY REQUESTING SUPPORT WHERE
WORKERS TAX CREDIT THAT WOULD
ALLOW ALL PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR WORKERS PAYING UNION DUES
TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR A REFUNDABLE
TAX CREDIT EQUAL 233% OF UNITY
AT THE END OF THE TAX. YEAR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU RYAN
FOR NINE PLEASE CALL. THE
CHAIRMAN RAM YOU NUMBER OF MANY
ROBERT HARRIS ON THE OF THE I
CAL. ARE WE WANT TO PLUG THE
BILL PARCHMENT. THANK YOUNG
OUTSIDE THE BAR. AND COMING UP
WITH THE TRAIN YOU SLICE THEM
THE AND INTERNSHIPS FOR WORKERS
AND THAT TUITION REIMBURSEMENT
PROGRAM. HOWEVER WE WOULD LIKE
THOSE THAT ADDED YEAH- GREAT SO
EXHILARATION AND THEN THE- OTHER
THING WHICH IS THE CORE STAFFING
FORMULA THOSE ARE CRITICAL THE
OTHER THINGS ARE GREAT ADDITIONS
. ARE WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SAY
. THANK YOU TO THE DEPARTMENT
FOR THE PILOT- RESULTS SUPPORTS
WE THINK THAT'S VERY INNOVATIVE
AND SO GOOD GOOD GOOD IDEA- WE
ALSO WANT TO SAY THE LEAST WE
SUPPORT THE EARLY START
ELIGIBILITY ACCELERATION. AND
GETTING READY TO HAVE THE
BILLING AND THE FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT SERVICES WITH SELF
DETERMINATION BOTH. JEWS THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO PAY FOR THAT
AND THEN FINALLY WE WOULD APPLY
THE SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY
GRANT PROGRAM BECAUSE THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT IN THIS. AND WHAT
THAT I ALSO WANT TO SAY I'M
SORRY I DON'T KNOW WHAT ALL THE
STUFF THAT THE- MISS WHITE WAS
GOING TO SAY HOPEFULLY SHE'LL
CALL BACK. HELP THANK YOU VERY
KIND. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD PERFECT- HI EVERYONE MY
NAME IT'S JUST YOU THING- THE
DIRECTOR PROGRAMS THAT
CALIFORNIA CHANGE LAWYERS- I'M
JUST- ADDRESSING EVERYONE STATE
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE INCLUSION
OF THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRATION
LEGAL FLLOWSHIP PROGRAM IN THE
NAY REVISED FIVE MILLION. BUT WE
ARE ASKING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
EXPAND THIS AMOUNT TO THE HOTEL
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST- THIS
INVESTMENT WILL ADDRESS ISSUES
OF EQUITY AND WILL CONTINUE TO
CONTINUE THE FIRST STATEWIDE
PROGRAM TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
IMMIGRATION COUNSEL IN THE MOST
UNDERSERVED RURAL REGION OF THE
STATE- I JUST FELT LIKE TO
MENTION THAT AS SOMEONE WHO-
BOARD PRESIDENT OF A FRESNO
BASED NONPROFIT CHICANA MOVEMENT
AND IF SOMEONE HAS CALLED- THE
CENTRAL VALLEY HOME FOR OVER TWO
DECADES I CAN ATTEST TO THE FACT
THAT OUR COMMUNITY AT. THIS
DARKLY LACK PROBABLE LEGAL
SCRIPTED AN ATTORNEY THAT CAN
HELP KEEP FAMILIES TOGETHER
WITHOUT THIS FUNDING- I BELIEVE
WILL BE MISSING OUT STORE
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD ON
SOMETHING THAT ALREADY TRULY
SPECIAL THE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE. AND
ALLOW CURRENT CODE OF. THE
PROGRAM AND WHAT THEY'VE- IN THE
AND A HALF- IN ME WHAT THEM
DIRECT. BOTH THE FELLOW AND THE
PART. OR HAVE BEEN AMAZING THE
IN AND OF ITS- IT'S CRITICAL
THAT WE GET THE FULL TEN MILLION
DOLLARS- SO THAT WE CAN HELP
DEVELOP LEGAL CAPACITY. FOR
COMMUNITIES AND UNDERSTAND THAT
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES ARE
BILLS THAT PERSON LANGUAGE
BACKGROUND CULTURE AND MORE. SO
THAT WE CAN EXPAND THIS WORK IN
OTHER IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING MY OWN. SOME OF THE
COMES WITH THE JOB WE SIX
BACKGROUND. I'M CONFIDENT THAT
THIS INVESTMENT OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR STRENGTH IN THE
REGION SUCH AS CENTRAL VALLEY
BUT ALSO PROVIDE RELIEF. TO THE
ALREADY OVERSTRETCHED
ORGANISATION IN REGIONS LIKE LOS
ANGELES. AND THE BAY AREA WHICH
BENEFIT OUR STATE SO AGAIN I
URGE YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
EXPANSION. OF THIS PROGRAM AND
WOULD INSTEAD HOPE THAT YOU WILL
ENSURE THAT. THESE RESOURCES
REACHED A HIGH. AT THE END
STATE. OF THE TENEMENT EXPENSE.
THANK SO MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ROBERT COPELAND I BELONG
TO A DISABILITY RIGHTS GROUP
CANCEL RECALL DATA RIGHT I'LL
CALL BACK YEAH THE FIREPLACE IN
THE FIFTY- CALL INCREASE WILL BE
A COMING OUT TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
I LIKE TO MOVE WITH THE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WHICH WOULD HELP A
LOT OF PEOPLE GET THEIR FIVE.
BETTER STRUGGLING TO PAY THE
RENT OR AT OR AT RISK OF
BECOMING HOMELESS AND ALSO A ONE
TIME GRANT SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
WOULD BE- BENEFICIAL FOR PEOPLE
INTENSIFIED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU GREAT TO HEAR FROM YOU NEXT
CALL PLEASE. THANK YOU I THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN ARAMBULA MEMBERS
THIS IS REBECCA GONZALES OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER I'M
GOING TO ECHO WHAT ROBERT JUST
BAD ABOUT SFI ASSETS HE- WE
REALLY NEED TO DIRECT THE BUDGET
SURPLUS TO COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
MOST IN NEED SUCH AS THESE
RECIPIENTS AND THE SENATE IN
THEIR BLUEPRINT DID XCELERATED
INCREASES TO THE GRANT. ANY ALSO
PROVIDED EIGHTY- AS AN
ADDITIONAL GRANT FOR THESE
RECIPIENTS- IN MANY COUNTIES WE
KNOW THAT THE GRANT IS NOT COVER
THE COST OF THE STUDIO APARTMENT
AND THESE RECIPIENTS ALSO NEED
TO PAY FOR UTILITIES FOOD
MEDICINE TOILETRIES CLOTHING AND
OTHER NECESSITIES WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE OTHER CALLERS WHO
CALLED AND ABOUT THE FACT
INCLUDE FOR ALL- AND WE WANT. TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THEY YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
INSURABLE A MEMBERS MEETING THE
FIFTEEN TRACK FROM GREAT AND
HELPFUL IN CALIFORNIA THE
CRADLES CARE COALITION
CONFIDENTIAL SUPPORT EQUIPMENT
THE PUBLIC FAVORITE UNDER ISSUE
TWO ONE FIVE AND ISSUE TWO ONE
SECOND APARTMENT FINANCE WTER
WE APPRECIATE. COMBINED ON THE
FOURTH FROM THE FAVORITE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S NEWLY REVISED FOR
EXACTLY EARNERS LEGISLATURE
FORTY FUND THE NINETY TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION PROJECT CHAMPIONED
BY SOMEBODY NUMBER ME UPON
TOUCHING SURE CORPORATE SUPPORT
A MORE CRITICAL ORGANIZATIONS
SUCH AS PARTNER CRADLES CLEAR
WORKING LOW INCOME COMMUNITY TO
MAKE SURE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
ARE SUPPORTED REPORT BERKELEY
COLLEGE AND CAREER IT CAN BE
DONE DE CALIFORNIA COORDINATED
NEIGHBORHOOD AND COMMUNITY
PARKS. PROGRAM I FORTY FUNDING
PLEASE TAKE THE COURTS TO SOME
DIFFERENT PROGRAM WILL OFFER
GREATER ANTI POVERTY ALLEVIATION
AS REMARKS MANY COMPACT OR
SERVICES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I ARE BLOOD COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BY NAME IS SEAN YOUNG ON
THE OF THE JEFF FROM IN THE
OFFICE THE CAMP THE TREASURER
I'M INTERESTED JUSTICE AND CHILD
SUPPORT COLLECTION BOB CULTURE
TO TAKE THE- TO COMMEND GOVERNOR
DAYTON'S. ON IMPROVED CAL CHILD
SUPPORT THE AND ENSURE THAT
CHILD SUPPORT DOLLARS GO OVER
THE- CHILDREN FROM THE GOVERNOR
AND THE PLEDGE AND DON MORE THAN
ANY OTHER OUR STATE'S HISTORY TO
SUPPORT FAMILY THE CHILD SUPPORT
SYSTEM BOB AND OUR COALITION
RESPECTFULLY URGES THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO BUILD ON THIS
TRACK RECORD. AND ENSURE THAT
1100% OF CHILD SUPPORT DOLLARS
GO TO THE POOREST CHILDREN AND
PARENTS INTERSTATE WHICH ARE
FAMILIES CURRENTLY RECEIVING
ASSISTANCE FROM COUNTY. THE HELP
OF THE 202-020-2020 THREE BUDGET
BLUEPRINT- ALSO WANT TO ECHO%
COMMENTS MADE BY THE WESTERN
CENTER BOB IT HIGHLIGHTS THAT
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OF CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS DO NOT GO TO. COMBAT
WORK MUCH OF OUR BLACK AND BROWN
I'M BILL PAYMENTS ARE INSTEAD
KEPT BY THE STATE OVER HALF. OF
FAMILY THINK. AND WE KNOW THAT
THE GOVERNOR BY A THE
LEGISLATURE. SHARE COALITION. TO
RACE AND I. JUSTICE ON THE TOPIC
THERE WHEN PERCENT. COTTON
PAYMENTS TO THOSE THAT. FAMILIES
I WOULD BE TRANSFORMATIVE UPPER
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
WE HOPE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
AND OF THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER. TO
INCLUDE THE FULL PATH THROUGH TO
ALL FAMILIES ARE STATE CHILD
SUPPORT SYSTEM I'M INDIAN ACTED
BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
HEALTHCARE POLICY ADVOCATE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NINE CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES NINE TO FIVE THE
GOVERNOR'S AND WAVERING
COMMITMENT TO STRENGTHENING THE
ENTIRE CARE CONTINUUM FOR USE.
I'M CALLING TO EXPECT URGENT
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT NSW AND
CAROLINE EIGHTEEN POINT SEVEN
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSAL
TO STABILIZE FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES WITHOUT ABLE AT THE
STATE THERE WILL NOT BE
SUFFICIENT HOME BASED LICENSE
FOR FOSTER YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE VISION OF C. C. R. WILL
NOT BE ACHIEVED. ADDITIONALLY IT
IS OUR HOPE THAT THE
UNPRECEDENTED FAMILY FINDING
DOLLARS INCLUDED IN THE
COMPANY'S REVISED AND DISCUSSED
IN HEARING WILL ALSO BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO COMMUNITY. BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. ANSWERING
INTENSIFIED PLANNING FOR YOU.
FINALLY WE ENCOURAGE YOU. OF
FURTHER DOLLARS THE CO RELIEF
FOR SHORT TERM RENTAL CARE COOK
IN BATCH. THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR- TO CRUCIAL. THE YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. DOCTOR
ARE BULLARD THE BOTTOM YOU'RE
SCARED HI WE ARE RUNNING WHAT
THE- STARTED WE'RE HAVING A REAL
HARD TIME SIR HEARING YOU DO YOU. CAN YOU SPEAK INTO THE
MICROPHONE. LET ME CRISIS BETTER
NOW. WE'RE STILL HAVING A HARD
TIME RECEIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OR
HEARING- YOU AT ALL WELL I WILL
TACKLE THE STATE THROUGH THERE
RIGHT NOW BUT AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE STAIRS. WHAT WORKS BETTER
WHAT PART OF THAT HEY JACKIE.
THE BEST. BOB AND I WILL BE ABLE
TO GET RID OF IT BUT HAPPY TO
BIRTHDAY. AND GOOD BYE. OPERATOR
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YOUR RAIMES SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
HELLO MY NAME IS RACHEL FREE
DANCE AND I AM A MEMBER THAT
TRUTH AND JUSTICE IN CHILD
SUPPORT COALITION I'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE ON WITH THE COMMENTS
ALREADY MADE BY THE WESTERN
CENTER AND THAT CAN BE PICKED A
FINANCIAL JUSTICE PROJECT. AND
I'M ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO
EXPAND- THE CHILD SUPPORT TO ALL
FAMILIES IN THE PROGRAM TO MAKE
SURE THAT 1100% HAVE CHILD
FOOTBALL PLAYERS GET DIRECTLY TO
THE FAMILIES THAT ARE NOT
INTERCEPTED BY THE STATE. WE
WOULD URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR TO EXTEND
THE POLICY TO THE FAMILIES
CURRENTLY ON CAL WORKS CHIU
ALONG WITH THOSE THAT WORK
FORMERLY ON HOW WORK. AT THE
TICKET NOW LOW INCOME MOTHERS
AND CHILDREN ARE OFTEN UNAWARE
OF HOW MUCH FATHERS ARE ACTUALLY
PAYING CHILD SUPPORT THEY ONLY
RECEIVE A PORTION OF EACH
PAYMENT BUSINESS UNDERSTANDING
CREEK COMPLICATED DISTRACT
WITHIN FAMILIES AND AS A RESULT
THEY INTERCEPTED MONEY USED TO
FUND PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
TRACKS NON CUSTODIAL PARENTS
OPTED FATHERS. THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY LACK CONTACT WITH
CHILDREN TO BE ELECTED EACH WITH
SEVENTEEN. PROVIDE LET
FREQUENTLY THANK THE POOR. WE
KNOW THAT GOVERNOR. DID MANAGE
TO AND LEGISLATURE WANT ENSURE
THAT THE CHAO WHAT IMPACT
SUPPORT FAMILIES IN OUR- AND
ENSURING THAT WERE HUNDRED. OF
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS. GO TO
FACE. CURRENTLY POP BENEFITS.
THE DEFENSE WOULD TRANSFERRED.
FOR LOWER TO. AND HOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NOT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHT SIX SIX.
I'M ABOUT TO LIGHT A LOT BETTER
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT NOW
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE ARAMBULA AND
MEMBERS MANY OF MY PATIENTS
ALREADY BY PRESIDENT OF PROGRAM
OPERATIONS WITH SPCS SAN DIEGO
CALLING HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF. FOR PROFIT NEIGHBORHOODS
UNDER ISSUE TWO ONE FIVE AND
ISSUE TWO ONE SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RYAN SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I'M STEPHEN
PRESIDENT OF PRESIDENT OF THE
AUTISM SOCIETY SAMPLES THE BAY
AREA REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES WHOSE CHILDREN ADULTS
ARE DISABLED BY ARTISTS MIGHT
ALSO PARENT OF A SEVERELY
AUTISTIC TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD
YOUNG MAN. AS YOU KNOW THE
CRITICAL WORKFORCE CRISIS IS
CAUSED THE COLLAPSE MAJOR
CENTRAL SERVICES FOR COUNTLESS
FAMILIES INCLUDING MY OWN WE ASK
THE GOVERNOR TO NEWSMEN
LEGISLATORS FIX THE DISABILITY
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE BY
ACCELERATING ALREADY PROVED.
FUNDING TO REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES. TO ALLOW SERVICE
PROVIDER RESULT TO PAY THEIR
STAFF. LIVING WAGES NOW
CURRENTLY WAGES FOR CAREGIVERS
ARE NOT COMPETITIVE WITH
EMPLOYERS LIKE MCDONALD'S OR
TARGET WEEK WE NEED ASSISTANCE
NOW IT SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE TO RATION
SERVICES AND ARE UNABLE TO
RECRUIT HIRE MAINTAIN. MEDICAL
WORKFORCE DDS DISMISSED IN
CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED FOR
YEARS AND JUST CAN'T COMPETE
WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO
ATTRACT AND RETAIN STAFF THIS IS
A REAL CRISIS. WE ALSO ASK THAT
YOU PROVIDE MEANS NOW TO HIRE
MORE SERVICE COORDINATORS WHO
RESPONSIBLE FACILITY
FACILITATING PROGRAMS AND- THANK
CARE FOR DEVELOPING STABLE
CLIENTS. THIS IS A CHRONIC
UNDERFUNDING HAS RESULTED IN
UNREALISTICALLY HIGH AND ILLEGAL
CASELOADS FOR EACH SERVICE.
COORDINATOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
RYAN EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEP
FOR THE AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
KATIE CRUEL I'M CAN AFFECT
FAMILIES STARKEL ADULT DAY
HEALTH CARE CENTER IN VENTURA
COUNTY.WE HAVE SOARED IN A LOW
INCOME SENIOR DISABLED ADULTS IN
AND MILITARY VETERANS. FOR OVER
NINETEEN YEAR. I'M CALLING TO
SUPPORT IT COULD BE TWO THREE
THREE ONE THE REQUESTED FOR
FIFTY FOUR POINT ONE MILLION IN
ONE TIME FAN STATE FINDING. TO
CREATE THE BRIDGE TO RECOVERY
FOR QUALITY SERVICES AKLAVIK
NINETEEN MITIGATION AND IT IS
THE LEAD GRANT PROGRAMS. OF THE
FUNDING WILL ALLOW OUR MORE
VULNERABLE POPULATION TO HAVE A
CORPORATE ENVIRONMENT WAS
URGENTLY NEEDED SAFETY UPGRADES
VENTILATION. SYSTEM AND THE
TRANSPORTATION. I THE FINDINGS
WILL OF THREE CREW AND RETAIN IN
SAY DURING THAT FOR. FOCUS WELL
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING OF THE
CONTAINER OUR SORORITY TOP
NURSES THERAPISTS DRIVER AIDS
AGREES THEIR LIVES CARING FOR
HUNDREDS OF ISOLATED- WARRAGUL
SIERRA. AND THERE CAN FOR YEARS
. THE DELIVERED MEALS THEY
BELIEVE VERY COMMUNICATION
ADMINISTERED MEDICATION PROVIDED
TREATMENTS. SHOP SO THESE PEOPLE
WILL STAY STAY FOR AN END TO
SUPPORT THAT DURING THIS
HORRIBLE TIME IN THEIR LIFE. SO
PLEASE OF SUPPORT FIFTH OF THE
OIL BASED SERVICES FOR OUR
SENIORS AND COMPETITIVE WAGES
FOR OUR EXCELLENT STAFF. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RAIMES
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
GERRYMANDERING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MANY MINUTES WHICH OF THE-
PUBLIC AFFAIRS MANAGER WITH.
COACHING WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS BUDGET PLAN
ALLOCATION OF CAPUCHIN AT THAT
TRIP IN THE CONSTRICTED BY THE
NUMBER BUT WE ARE DISAPPOINTED
THAT HIS MAIN PREDICTION THIS
OPPORTUNITY CHECK SURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS THE TO
THE CITIZENS WE STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO PRIORITIZE FOOD FOR ALL
AN EXPERIENCE HE PATH AND TO
CALIFORNIANS. OF ALL AGES
REGARDLESS OF THE IMMIGRATION
STATUS ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO REQUEST THE UNDER
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
INTO CAPTIVITY INTO THINK
RESPONDING. TO THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE YOU NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU RITE AID FOUR PLEASE
AHEAD. THANK YOU- DOCTOR A LOT
FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN YOUR
CAMPAIGN FOR THE DVD SERVICES
SECRETARY POWELL WITH
POWERPOINT- I APPRECIATE YOUR
CHANTING THE PROPOSAL TO THE
COLOR TO THE RIGHT STUDY AS WELL
AS THEY DO IN ADDENDUM TO THE
RIGHT STUDY TO FIX AND IMPROVE
IT AS WELL AS PROVIDE REGULAR
UPDATES THAT WE DON'T GET INTO
THAT SITUATION AGAIN. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT THE MONEY IN THE
RATE STUDY WILL GO TO FRONTLINE
STAFF AND IT SHOULD BE A
COMPLIANCE SERVICES MY AGENCY IS
CURRENTLY DOWN A HUNDRED FORTY
ONE OF FORTY IT'S WITHOUT ANY
FURLOUGHS OR LAYOFFS AND THE
REAL ISSUE OF IN WHAT YOU JUST
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT IT
WILL HELP. THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH IBD WELCOME TO
PORT THE FIXES FOR THE CORE
STAFFING FORMULA FOR REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICE COORDINATORS. BUT
MINISTRY TO PULL THE HALF THE
BILL- IN THE NATION. TAYLOR DATA
SERVICE CHAIN. WORKFORCE AND
THAT. HELLO COULD HI. INCREASE
EQUITY GRANT THANK. FAMILY
SUPPORT SERVICES. AND THE EFFORT
. IN CONTROL YOUR SEATS. THE YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
RYAN FIFTY PLEASE CALL. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ARAMBULA AND
MEMBER JIM ROBB CHILD NUMBER OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC AT FOR
IHS CALLING IN REGARDS TO THE
IHS A PERMANENT BACKUP PROVIDER
SYSTEM WE APPRECIATE THE
INCREASE OF UP TO A HUNDRED
SIXTY HOURS FOR RECIPIENTS TO
ACCESS A BACKUP PROVIDER SYSTEMS
AND FOR PUSHING OUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION START DATE TO
OCTOBER. WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO REVIEWING THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.WHEN THAT COMES OUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
RYAN FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ARAMBULA
AND MEMBERS IF THIS RICHARD RIOT
WITH META MISSION ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY IN SAN
FRANCISCO CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE FIFTH AT FOUR
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD UNDER
ISSUES TWO ONE FIVE TWO TWO ONE
SIX. WE'RE HAPPY TO SEE TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EXISTING
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE. WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO FUND THE
NINETY TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET PASSED. CHAMPION
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIA BONTA.
THE FUNDS NEW AND EXISTING
CRADLE TO CAREER INITIATIVE
ACROSS THE STATE. WE BELIEVE
THIS IS A CRITICAL PART OF AN
EQUITABLE RECOVERY STRATEGY FOR
OUR HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES.
PROVIDE WRAPAROUND SUPPORT THE
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
MOVING THEM OUT OF POVERTY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU YOUR MIND FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I DON'T
BELIEVE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
HEALTH PROJECTS CENTER IN THE
DELMAR CARE TO RESEARCH RESEARCH
SANTA CRUZ MODERATE SAN BENITO
COUNTY I'M BOTH REPRESENTING
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA ARE W.
SEVENTH. WE ARE THE ONLY STATE
FUNDED CENTER THAT CAL OVER THE
ACT. YEAR WHAT WE SUPPORT OF
THAT. WHITE CARE TWENTY EIGHT AT
THE TDA. WE FORWARD TO CALL.
WITH THE SHOULD CONTINUE IT
THANK GOODNESS INTEGRITY OF OUR
WHY QUITE NEED NOT CARE. I
DIDN'T PROGRAM THROUGH THE CAN
STATEWIDE ACT BY HIGH QUALITY OF
EVIDENCE TO INTERVENTIONS TO
KEEP FIGURE DEVELOP. EMPLOYEES
BETTER ABLE TO CARE FOR THE ONE
VEHICLE. OUR DATA SHOWS THAT THE
FAMILY B. SEATED THIRD ARE
DIVERSE OF THE 40% COMING
THROUGH I THINK WE GET DIVERSE
POPULATION. INCLUDING FROM SOME
OF THE MOST REMOTE RURAL REGIONS
THAT ARE FAKE OUR DATA SO THAT
THE FAMILIES WE SERVE. I'M FINE
I WOULD DOUBLE THE- NUMBER OF
HOURS UNPAID FARE THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE THE. CARE
GIVERS. THERE ARE BY THE COMP
CARE PUTTING STRAIN ON FAMILY.
THE WITH YOUR TAKE HOME. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING CLOSELY WITH
DIRECTOR STUDENT TOMORROW AT
FIFTY EIGHT PORT MASTER PLAN I
NEED TO FORTY CALIFORNIA THERE'D
THANK YOU.
REPORTS CENTER FOR OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
IN ORDER THE LOS ANGELES AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY WE LIKE TO
THINK THE GOVERNOR FOR CRATER
CRADLE TO CAREER INVESTMENTS AS
WELL AS HEALTHCARE BENEFITS
BEING HEARD TODAY AND ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION BUT TO. HOWEVER WE
MISS WE THOUGHT WE MISSED
OPPORTUNITY NAME DURING THE MAY
REVISED- FOR THIS EPIC DURING
THIS EPIC TIME OF A CHILD CARE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE THE CURRENT
PROVIDER REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE
BASED ON TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REGIONAL MARKET RATE OPERATE
CHILDCARE. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
MINIMUM WAGE IN CALIFORNIA WAS
ELEVEN DOLLARS PER HOUR IT'S
TWENTY TWENTY TO THE MINIMUM
WAGE IS NOW FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER
HOUR THAT THE 27% INCREASE FOR
ACCOUNT HEALTHCARE WORKERS. THE
MAY REVIVE ALSO PROPOSES AN
INCREASE TO FIFTEEN FIFTY PER
HOUR BRINGING THE TOTAL TO PAY
WORKERS AFTER THIRTY PERCENT.
SELL BILL INCREASE THE MINIMUM
WAGE COSTS ALSO OUR LEVEL TO
CLIMB AND THE NAY REVISION GETS
TO KNOW WHAT THE **** FUNDING
FOR HEALTH CARE PROGRAM. HE
THEIR HIGHLY AT. WORK WE KNOW
THAT AND CASES- WORKER ARE BEING
MORE AT THE END OUT AND BE
FINING BOTH AND OUR WAGES THIS
IS NOT ENOUGH SO WE CAN OUR WORK
FOR OUT FOR YOUR SUPPORT
INCREASE REMEMBER RATE. SO
THAT'S HOW CAN IN PAY THEIR FOR
WE CANNOT AND RECRUIT THEM THANK
YOU. THE YOU NOT CALLER PLEASE.
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT THIRTY SIX
GO OUT. HELLO MY NAME IS
JENNIFER FOR FOX FROM THERE AND
CANNELLA INCOME. AYE MR HERE
COULD NOT PREVENT ALL SPEAKER
CURRENTLY RECEIVING TALENT
SENATE OFFENSE FOR THE CAR.
IN THE PUBLIC PROGRAM BY LISTING
THE GRANT BY INCREASING. THE
GRANT. TO EXISTENCE LEVEL CLASS%
ONE. I'M HAPPY THAT THE GOVERNOR
FOOTBALL OF THE BALL FELL TO
COURT. PALESTINE FORGET ABOUT IT
THE FAMILY STAY ON WORKS MIKE
KID MAKES THAT ALL CHIU SUPPORT
PASS THROUGH TO THE CALL WHAT
ALSO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
ME TO. THANK YOU. NEXT CALL
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE SEVEN
THREE GO AHEAD. I COULD HAVE
DOCTOR A AND SHARE THEM- THIS IS
DEREK HOLE POLICY AND READ
MANNER CRAIG LAW ANGELES FOOD
BANK AND I WANTED TO PURSUE BASE
THAT HAVE- PRETTY CLEAR- SUPPORT
FOR. INITIATIVE IN THE BY.
HOWEVER I LIKE TO ASK. THE
URGING- DETAILED PICA MARKER
OTHERS- ASK THE AND LEGISLATURE
TO FIND OUT WE FIND FAR COULDN'T
IS THAT WOULD BE ONE TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE. FOR THEY
CAN PREPARE A HUNDRED EIGHTY IT
THAT'S- THE AND THE WHOLE
EXPERIENCE OF THE HEALTHCARE. M.
THROUGH THE ROOF FOR ALL-
CRITICAL MOMENT NOW AND HIS
MOMENT BUT WE HAVE A RED RECORD
BUDGET THROUGH- BUT HE THE-
RECORD EIGHTY. AND- WE'RE JUST
LOOK. AT THE BUT I- YOU PLACE IN
THE ON OVER TO GET WORK FROM
HERE. AND I KNOW PEOPLE SMOKE
ABOUT INTERNET MAC AT THE ISSUE
FROM THIRTY NEEDS A- BUT THE
AFTER THE BROUGHT IS GOING TO
CAUSE FOOD- RIGHT THAT THE EIGHT
. SO WE'RE SEEING NOW IS ONLY
GONNA GET WORSE AND-
THANK YOU LEVINE EIGHTY ONE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON BACKED
ARAMBULA MANY THAT ARCTIC ARCTIC
ARE WE GOING TO COMPROMISSO
REPRESENTING THE VOICE THE MORE
FIVE THOUSAND THAT SENSE OF
UNITY KILL WORKERS ACROSS. I AM
HERE ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT THE
MAKE CALIFORNIA THE FIRST STATE
IN THE NATION THAT ADDRESS
PLEASE THE CUTIE WITH A REAL
ACTION I HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
PROGRAM SO WE COMMUNITY
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
WITH. VERY MCCARTY. IT WILL HELP
IN KEEP I FELT THE AND LIFE BUT
THEY ON THE PHONE. SPEAKING OF
THE DAY THAT IN WAY THANK TO
THEIR WORKFORCE CALIFORNIA HAS
ALMOST DOUBLED THE FACT THE PART
HERE ARE THREE THIRTY THREE NOT
A PRIVILEGE. THANK YOU IN
ADVANCE FOR OLD FOR ALL OF YOU
FOR MAKING THAT HAPPEN. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU A THREE PRETTY GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS DONNA YOU'RE I'M WITH THAT I
CAN KEEP I LIVE IN FACT HAVE A-
I WANT THINK ABOUTAND THE-
COUPON STATE WHICH WAS BENEFITS
FOR ANY. A FIFTY FIVE OVER A THE
MEDIA. GROWING UP IN MIX ON
HOUSEHOLD IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT
BECAUSE WE STRUGGLED STUDENTS.
WHY BECAUSE I'M A WAS IN THE AND
I'LL FOR HOW FESH THEREFORE I'M
CHAIRED URGE- THE ASSEMBLY CAN
BUILD ON OUR AND FULLY FOR
PORTION ALL THE FORCE FOUR FIVE
SPENDING THE OUTSIDE OF TO. OF
ALL AGE REGARDLESS OF A STATUS
WELL IT A PERMANENT FULL THAT
WILL ADDRESS THE THANK ISSUE THE
SIX AND IMMIGRANT. THANK YOU.
THANK PLEASE. COPYRIGHT SEVENTY
PLEASE GO OUT. THE DOCTOR DOC
AND THANK YOU SO FOR SEATS. OF
THE IN WILL TO DIRECTOR FOR- MY
NAME IS ONE BACKER I AM OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE ARCTIC
CAL- WE ARE THE LARGEST. FAMILY
FUNDED FOUNDED AND LED
ORGANIZATION FOR PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES- MY
SON LIVES IN AN APARTMENT IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND HAS LOST A NUMBER
OF SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS. DUE TO COBIT
OR THE WAGE AND PROBLEMS THAT
WE'VE HAD IN ORDER TO PAY OUR
STAFF. I APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS
TO ACCELERATE THE RIGHT MODEL
AND I HOPE THAT THAT WILL MOVE
FORWARD INTO THE FINAL REVISION
OF THE BILL THE BUDGET. ALSO I
AM IN SUPPORT OF FIXING THE CORE
STAFFING FOR BEYOND THE CLIENT
OF THE REGIONAL CENTER WE'VE
ALSO HAD THREE DIFFERENT
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICE
COORDINATORS IN THE COURSE OF
THE LAST YEAR WHY BECAUSE THEY
QUIT. THEY QUIT BECAUSE THEY'RE
BIRDS OUT AND I'M JUST TRYING TO
PUT A FACE ON TO THE ISSUES THAT
YOU ARE ALREADY SUPPORTING TO
THANK YOUR SUPPORT. I ALSO. THE
RESUMPTION OF FEES ON FAMILIES
THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO START
JANUARY FIRST. IT'S APPALLING TO
ME TO THINK THAT WE WOULD BE SO-
STARTING TO CHARGE FAMILIES
AGAIN. AND HE JUST NEEDS TO BE
ELIMINATED ALTOGETHER AND- I.
ALSO AND- GLAD. SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTER- PROPOSAL IS VALERIE
DS I AM THE GRANT IN. BECAUSE I
CERTAINLY ON. AND TO GOD IT IS
THE YOU KNOW IT'S A MONTH TO
MONTH BATTLE FOR HIM SO I'M
PUTTING A FACE. TO THE PROPOSALS
THAT I KNOW A LOT OF YOU ALREADY
SUPPORT. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FROM ALL THE FAMILIES OF
THE ARK OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
RYAN SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SEVEN THREE. WE'LL
TRY LINE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI ANKIT AFTERNOON DOCTOR
AND ARAMBULA AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS VICTORIA
BERRY I'M A PARENT OF TWO YOUNG
ADULT MEN WHO ARE CONSUMERS AT
THE REGIONAL CENTER. AND EVERY
WEEK I WORRY THAT I'LL GET
NOTIFIED THAT ONE OF THEIR STAFF
IS LEAVING FOR A BETTER PAYING
JOB. SO I AM CONTACTING YOU
TODAY TO ASK- FOR SUPPORT FOR DR
ARAMBULA PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
WAGES FOR DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS AND- ACCELERATE
HE- BREAK PROPOSAL. I AM ALSO IN
SUPPORT AND THE PROPOSAL TO-
MODIFIED THE STAFFING FORMULA
FOR SERVICE COORDINATORS AT
REGIONAL CENTERS BECAUSE- THEY
ALSO ARE. VERY OVERWORKED I HAVE
A LOT OF CASES AND I'M ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO BRINGING BACK THE
FAMILY FEES. FOR REGIONAL CENTER
CONSUMERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RYAN THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THE
STATE'S REGIONAL MARKET FROM THE
LAW CENTER FOR CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
REFINING ANY KEEPS IMPRINT.
INVITE ALL THE LEGISLATOR HE
SAID I CAN I CAN I INTENDED TO
ENSURE THAT THE FUNDING NEEDS I
FOUND FOR THAT SPECIFIC PURPOSE
AND FAMILY AND- PRODUCT. OFFERED
AGENCIES. IT OFFERS AND YOUTH TO
BE ABLE TO REMAIN OUR COMMUNITY
AND WITH FAMILY. ALL DR. UP
FRONT FAMILY PROCESS RIGHT GO TO
BE OF THE- HOW WHICH PEOPLE ON
FAMILY. AND OR MORE THAN A
PERCENT OF CHILDREN WERE ABLE TO
STAY WITH. HI PROGRAM. AFTER
ENGINE THE PROGRAM ABOUT 50% OF
GREAT TO. CAN WE JUST. HIGH THAN
EIGHT AFTER IQ 40% OF CHILDREN.
PLEASE PREVENTING THE CONGREGATE
CARE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
RYAN FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON THE CONFINEMENT
TRAFFIC PLEDGING. SUPPORT THE
SENATE BUDGET PLAN WHICH
ACCELERATES TO INCREASE THE
DEFICIT BY IT. PROVIDES A ONE
TIME GRANT BENEFITS BY RECEIVING
AN EXPANSIVE TUITION BENEFITS TO
IMMIGRANTS OF ALL AGES.
CALIFORNIA THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF SENIORS LIVING UP
POVERTY MEASURE THE STATE WHICH
MEANS THAT MANY LOW INCOME. AS
WELL AS PEOPLE WITH. STRE TO
EVEN THE THEY. THE POST RECKONS
ABOUT SURPLUS HE PLEADED FOR
MORE THE NEW. BUT THE PIRATES.
HE ALSO SUPPORTED SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE FOR ALMOST PREVENTION
PROGRAM. FOR OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE DISABILITIES. REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES NOT BY TO A PM FOR
THEIR TRAINING IN LIGHT OF THE
ANSWER INCREASE FINANCE STUDENTS
WITH THE CHIEF FINANCIAL.
TRAINING FUNDING AND THEY THE PS
OF CULTURALLY AND TOM INFORMED.
LOS ANGELES SOUTHWEST COLLEGE I
AM ALSO THE MOTHER TO MAKE THEM
AND JOE L. AND JOSEPH- I'M GOING
TO BE IN SUPPORT- SO GOVERNOR'S
. PROPOSAL OF AN INCREASE OF 11%
FOR TOWER I'M ASKING THAT THE
COMMITTEE- FINALLY DECIDES TO
COME TO AN END TO THE PROPERTY
IN THE TOWERS PROGRAM BUYING TO
PREACHING GRANT. SO THAT THEY
ARE EQUAL TO ASSIST UNITS PLUS
ONE GRANT LEVELS I AM ALSO HAPPY
THAT THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING
TO PASS THROUGH ALL CHILD
SUPPORT FOR FORMER COLLEGE
FAMILIES BUT HE FORGOT ABOUT US.
THE FAMILY STILL CAN'T WORK LIKE
MINE PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT ALL
CHILD SUPPORT IS PASSED TO CUT
WORKING. FAMILIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RAIMES SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DOCTOR RAMBLING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PLANNING FAMILIAL CLOSER
ON THE SEAT- FOR THE ARK LOS
ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY. WE
ARE CALLING TODAY TO BE IN FULL
EFFECT AROUND PLUS A PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE WAGES FOR DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
ACCELERATING THE RATE
MULTIPLICATION IT'S A HOPELESS
WITH WORKFORCE RETENTION ALL THE
WAGES IN ALL SECTORS INCREASING
AND HOPE TO KEEP PACE WITH THE
WORK FORCE PUBLISHED FIFTEEN
ADVOCATE THAT WE HAVE WORKING
WITH INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES- WHICH COME IN. A
HARD PLACE TO FIND. A QUALIFIED-
A DEBATE. WHAT ARE WE THAT WITH
RESPECT CAN TAKE. OFF THE HARD
WORK THAT THEY DO WITH THEIR OF
. BUT A COUPLE PROGRAM. WHICH
BENEFIT THE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES- AS
WE'RE TRYING AND FIGHTING TO
WORK. TOWARDS KEEPING IN
RETAINING OUR CURRENT WORKFORCE
WHERE WE'RE PUTTING OUR MONEY-
AND OF COURSE THAT MONEY NEEDS
TO COME FROM SOMEWHERE AND SO.
WE JUST NEED MORE MORE REVENUE
TO BE ABLE TO NOT ONLY RETAIN
OUR WORK FORCE BUT ALSO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
PROGRAMS. WHAT THE FULL SUPPORT
OF PROPOSAL TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICE COORDINATORS. BUT FIXING
THE CORE STAFFING FORMULA.
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE PARTNERS IN
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICE
AND FULL CIRCLE RESOURCES TO
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS. WITH
REGIONAL FINANCE BEING
UNDERSTAFFED IT HINDERS OUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE ON TIME
RESOURCES TO FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS THAT SERVE. LEADER
REGIONAL CENTERS TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO HELP US
PROVIDE SERVICES IN THE FIELD.
BUT. STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
I WANT TO THANK YOU DOCTOR BLIND
ASSEMBLY MATTHEW THINK MAYBE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR SUPPORT
LEADERSHIP THE COUPLE US PROVIDE
SERVICES AND HAPPY TO THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTER AND
DEVELOPMENTAL. DISABILITIES THAT
WE SERVE THANK YOU AND HAVE A
GREAT DAY. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR AT ONLINE AND
TO MEETING MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PATRICIA I THANK YOUNG DIRECTOR
OF PROJECT AN OUTREACH AT THE
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA. NIEDER
WORKING AT THE FIRM YET ANY
PARENT OF AN INDIVIDUAL WITH A
DISABILITY WHO WITH THE CLIENT
AT THE REGIONAL CENTER. I'M
CALLING IN TO SUPPORT THE
INCREASED WAGES FOR DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL BY
ACCELERATING THE RATE MODEL. AND
FAMILY ARE WITHOUT SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS DUE TO CRITICAL
STAFFING SHORTAGES. MANY DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS ARE
CHOOSING OTHER OF WORK BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT RECEIVING
COMPETITIVE LIVING WAGES. I'M
ALSO COMING IN TO SUPPORT AT
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICE COORDINATORS. I
THINK THE CORE STAFFING FORMULA.
THE STATE BANK ACTING AT
REGIONAL CENTERS USING AN
OUTDATED FORMULAS THAT CAUGHT
PEOPLE'S KATO RATIOS INCREASE
OVER TIME. HI KEITH NO RACIAL
LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF TIME AND
ATTENTION SERVICE COORDINATORS
CAN PROVIDE TO MEET THE
INDIVIDUAL. OKAY WE CAN ALL OUR
SERVICES. THANK YOU LATEST
LEADER FREE EFFORT AND
COMMITMENT TO THAT OF
DISABILITIES. AND LACKS REMEMBER
THAT CALIFORNIANS WITH THE
FACILITY AND DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS. MR TO LIVE FULL
AND EQUITABLE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU RYAN EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
ARAMBULA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
THAT THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE DEAL
WITH MARRIAGE CALIFORNIA
COMMENTING ON CHIU CALFRESH
PROPOSALS THAT WOULD NOT
INCLUDED IN THE MAYBE FIVE. I
FIRST I WANT TO ACT THAT THE
FROM. CALLER ON THE FOOD
PROPOSAL. I'M NERVOUS CALIFORNIA
UP BOB. OUTPUT WELCOME MEMBERS
INCLUDING JEWISH AFFAIR
COMMITTEE UP TO. ARAFAT IN HIS
IN NEED OF THE PLAN. MEETING
THANK YOU. LONG BEACH ALLIANCE
FOR FOOD AND FITNESS. SECOND
HARVEST OF SILICON. SOUTH ASIAN
NETWORK AND THE FOOD BACK UPON
COSTA. APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSAL TO FANCY BENEFITS FOR.
FIFTY FIVE AND OVER. BUT RECENT
RESEARCH SHOWS. THAT A LOT.
THIRTY AMONG UNDOCUMENTED CAL OF
ALL AGES. SAID THAT ABOUT FORTY
FIVE TO. OF THE DOCTORS CAL.
OUR
STATE.
WE ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU CHEN
ARAMBULA FOR CHAMPIONING THIS
ISSUE. FINALLY WE ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THE CALHOUN PROGRAM. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE
THE STATE MAGICIAN SIGNETICS
PASSABLE EQUITABLE AND MEET THE
NEEDS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS NEED
HELP. PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK HEREBY NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
DOCTOR AND YOUR SHOW MEDINA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY CHOICE
ASSOCIATION. AND IF YOU PROVIDER
IS PROVIDING TESTIMONY AT THE
ONE HARING BUT HERE I AM-
COUNTY CA STRONGLY SUPPORTS ITEM
TWENTY FIVE WHICH IS THE ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS A
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA WE'RE JUST PAYMENT
PLAN- THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT WAS
INITIALLY ESTABLISHED. FUNDED IN
MY BUT THAT. THIS FUNDING IS.
REALLY BY THE PANDEMIC AND
UNABLE TO PAY THEIR YOU BILLS I
HAD NO BY THE L. A. THE CAP
PROGRAM WITHIN IX LAST YEAR
WITH THEM GOING OUT DOOR- TO
ADDRESS HE BILL- THE BILL DEBT
BOTH FICTIONALLY AN ACT.
THIS PROPOSAL HAS IMPACTED
PETITIONS FOR THE REPAIR THAT
COULD HAVE SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND THIS IS
SOMETHING. WILL NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT AS THE BUDGET-
DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE I.
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT NINETY FOUR
PEOPLE AT. HELLO YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI SORRY GIVE ME ONE
SECOND- I'M CALLING IN BASICALLY
IN SUPPORT OF OUR- GIVE ME ONE
MOMENT- UNDERTAKING MY NAME IS
TONY KAHN I'M CALLING IN ON
BEHALF OF YOUR SACRAMENTO THE
PROPOSAL INTO CORE OF THE
CALIFORNIA IN WILL BE HELLO
PROGRAM- I UNDER THAT THE
GOVERNOR- REPORTER US WITH A
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR- MAY REVISE
THE WE'RE HOPING THE FULL. TIME-
ACOSTA CENTER WILL NOT BE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS SENIOR
MANAGER WITH THE LOOK AT A
COALITION FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
OR L. SIXTY PER SHORT WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
BUDGET PLAN AND ALLOCATION OF
SEPA NUTRITION BENEFITS FOR
IMMIGRANTS FIFTY FIVE AND OVER
WE ALSO FEEL THAT THE MAY
REVISION MISSED AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ENSURE ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO PRODUCES. WE URGE THE
PRIORITIZATION OF GOOD FOR ALL
ANTICS. THAT BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIA ALL AGES REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS. WE KNOW
THAT PACKING FOOD FOR ALL WILL
MITIGATE HUNGER AND POVERTY BY
ENSURING THAT OUR STATE. HE
CHRISTIAN SYSTEMS DID NOT
DISCRIMINATE ON THE BASIS OF
APPLICATION STATUS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RYAN FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR FOUR. FIFTY
S. CALIFORNIA I APOLOGIZE BUT
EARLIER- THANK YOU DOCTOR
REGULAR IT'S I WANT TO KEEP A
FEW MINUTES TO SPEAK ON COUPLE
AYE SUPPORT BECAUSE FUNDING FOR
EMPLOYMENT UP ABOUT THE PLAN OF
AGING SUPPORT BY YOU TO TAKE
MINIMUM JOBS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
GOING. ON THE SPECIAL THAT I THE
DOCTOR TEAM OF I OF THAT FROM A
PROVIDER SYSTEMS FOR NOT TO
EMPLOYER EACH SUCH AS BILL BUT
AGAIN COULD CONVERT ON PROPOSED
WE ALSO ENCOURAGING OF THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION TO THE
PROGRAM THE NEXT AUTOMATIC.
SINCE THE AGE OF THE- WHICH WERE
NOT DIG. IN THE- PROPOSAL
SERVICE WE WOULDN'T. MORE AND
CAL. WE APPRECIATE THE FIFTY
MILLION FOR CARE GIVER APPROVAL
BUT THE FUNDED POLICY OF THE ONE
HUNDRED. NEED APART THANK. MIGHT
MIGHT BE A THREE. THE HIGH AND
FIFTY FOR. FUN BUT THEY THERE
NEEDS TO BE. FORTY AMONG COUNTY
THE WOULD HAPPEN SUPPORT OF
HUNDRED BUT THE FIRST THE
BETTER. NEEDS WE OPERATE. YOU TO
A IN THE FINAL BUDGET SIXTY NO.
FOR TO FILL THE HOLE FOR. PEOPLE
FOR THE JOB SUPPORT FACTORED BY
. I THOUGHT IT ALSO GONE FOR THE
CURRENT. BY AFTER YOUR- FOR. NOW
INCLUDED MAYBE. A JOINT PROPOSAL
BY L. A. K. BEAT THE- IN AT THE
ARE YOU. HUNDRED BILLION FOR THE
CURRENT GET THE STATE AND AT
LAKE JOB. THAT. WITHOUT THE-
THANK. THEY YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK HEREBY NINE SIX
PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TO
OUT ARAMBULA MEMBERS MEANS HAD A
GREAT WITH FIVE ALAMEDA CON IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSISTANCE FOR
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS UNDER
ISSUE TWO FIFTEEN AND TWO
SIXTEEN. THE STATE FRANKLY OF
MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND EXISTING
PRODUCTS NEIGHBORHOODS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE LEGISLATOR
TO FULLY FUND THE NINETY TWO
POINT FOUR BILLION BUDGET ASKED
CHAMPION BY A FAMILY MEMBER
BONTA TO ENSURE. FULL STATE
SUPPORT A CRADLE TO CAREER
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO MAKE SURE CHILDREN SUCCEED IN
SCHOOL. AND FAMILIES LIVE OUT OF
POVERTY. I'LL BE STARTING
COMMUNITY ARE. FOR DEVELOPING ON
MINDS AND FAMILY WILL BEING.
FINDS THAT THERE'S A DIRECT LINK
BETWEEN EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT AND COMMUNITY AND
FAMILY CONDITIONS. AND OUR STATE
STABILITY AND PROSPERITY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
LINE ONE OH THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. H. HI MY NAME IS GINA
HOUSTON I AM THE MOTHER OF JULIA
MATHESON JIA I AM THE PROUD BIRD
FEEDER FROM FULLERTON COLLEGE- I
JUST WANNA SAY THAT I'M REALLY
HAPPY THAT THE GOVERNMENT
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING A 11%
INCREASE IN CALVERT BROWN. BUT I
PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE AND ASKING
THE COMMITTEE TO FINALLY END YOU
PROPERTY THAT WE'RE ALL LIVING
IN I'M HERE IN THE CAL WORK
PROGRAM IN PLACE TO INCREASE THE
GRANT AT LEAST.ON AT THE
EQUIVALENT TO AN ASSISTANCE UNIT
PLUS ONE I KNOW PERSONALLY FOR
MYSELF- I'M GOING TO BE MOVING
OVER TO UC DAVIS I'M
TRANSFERRING IN THE FALL AND MY
WHOLE FAMILY ALL FIVE NUMBERS
HAVE BEEN LIVING. IN A LIVING
ROOM AND WE'RE BARELY MAKING IT
FROM MONTH TO MONTH I HAVE NO
IDEA HOW I PERSONALLY TO PUT A
FACE THAT THAT HOW I'M GOING TO
AFFORD FINISHING UP GOING TO
COLLEGE AND GETTING MYSELF OFF
OF THE WELFARE- I'M REALLY ALSO
VERY HAPPY THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING TO PASS THROUGH ALL
CHILD SUPPORT. PERFORMER CAL
WORK FAMILIES BY- FAMILIES LIKE
MINE STILL ON CAL WORKS WE WON'T
BE RECEIVING ALL THE MONEY. THAT
STOP. I WAS JUST WANTED TO ASK
FIFTIES MAKE SURE THAT ALL
THROUGHOUT THE- IS PAST. OUR
FAMILIES AS WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CARE ARAMBULA MEMBERS MY NAME IS
A FRIEND BUT A PERMISSION
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
EMISSIONS FROM THE SECTOR HAD.
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE
NO NETWORK AND I'M CALLING FROM
SUPPORT OF ASSISTANCE FOR
PROMISED A GOOD CENTER ISSUE.
TWO ONE FIVE IN ADDITION TO ONE
SIX. SHE GETS TO SEE THE- OF THE
TOP AND DOLLARS FIVE X. FROM
MAKE IT IN THE GULF TYPE BY.
NEARLY PERCHED IN. HOLDING BONTA
TWO FOUR BY TWO ASK CHAMPION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA TO ENSURE
FULL STATE SUPPORT UPGRADED
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION'S FOR
HAPPENED WORKING TO NEXT. SURE
CHILDREN KICKS IN SCHOOLS AND
FAMILIES WITHOUT A POVERTY.
PROGRAM FUND AND EQUITY FOCUSED
COORDINATED APPROACH AND
COMMUNITY BASED INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT HAS PROVIDED SERVICES TO
LOW INCOME CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
FOR THE PAST TEN YEARS. WE HAVE
A PROVEN PLAY STATES MODEL FOR
COLLECTIVE IMPACT. THAT FUTURE
PENALTY INTEREST FUND INTO THE
ECONOMIC DISPARITIES THE PART
THAT THE PANDEMIC'S CONTINUES TO
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN. THE
COMPANY OF THE MOST IMPACT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
RIDE ONE OUT PLEASE CALL AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON WITH THE GYM
MEMBERS MARKET THE RIVER
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SUPPORT OF
THE TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX
MILLION- HEARD THE INCREASE OF
CALORIE EXPRESS BETWEEN 11% BY
11% ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
THIRTY FOUR MILLION- ONGOING TO
ESTABLISH PERMANENT BACK TO
PROVIDERS THE TO FOR I. HSS
RECIPIENTS. AND WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE PROPOSED FIFTY FIVE
MILLION REDUCTION TO THE
ELIGIBILITY COMPONENT OF THE
CULPRIT SINGLE LOCATION BUT
SUPPORTIVE OF THE REQUEST FOR AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTY MILLION A
CALPERS ADMIN UNTIL YOU BUDGET
METHODOLOGY IS ADOPTED BUILT
URGED THE CRUCIBLE OF THE
COUNTY'S COSPONSORED PROPOSAL
WITH- SB A- QUICK. IN ANNUALLY
BEGINNING. TWENTY TWO THREE FOR
ONE COUNTY OFFERS. TO HELP THE
COUNTY THE BILL TO MAKE CRITICAL
WALKER SERVICES. THAT BEST
SUPPORT SHALL PEOPLE BE. TO GET
USED TO CUT THE TRADITION TO
INDEPENDENT YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU RYAN FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND. FOUR EIGHT. BLIND OH
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS VALERIE DID
NOW DIRECTOR OF POLICY IN
EDUCATION WITH ATHLETES HOW
CALIFORNIA WE AGREE WITH THE
CODE RELIEF PACKAGES WHICH
EXTEND WAIT IN A FAMILY PLEASE
HOLD HARMLESS AND SECURITY.
HOWEVER AS MINIMUM WAGE OTHER
ITEMS HAVE FINANCING COSTS IT IS
NOT PAID WITHIN ITSELF EIGHTEEN
NUMBER WE. URGE YOU TO ASK. WE
HEARD YOU AND MAKE DEFINITELY
ARE ASKING FOR AND NOT NEEDED
INCREASE IN RATES WHICH CARE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU ONE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CEMEX ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES REGION SCHOOL DOCTOR
DEPORT AUTO WE OUTLETS THEY BUT
MAJOR MEDICAL CONTROL FUNDING
FROM INVESTMENT THE
CALCIFICATION WHICH HEALTH
CANADA JUST. THAT INSURED AS OF
RIGHT NOW PERSONAL EXPENSES
PERCENT OF CANNABIS- PARTY
BUDGET REQUEST THE CUT
LEGISLATURE PACKAGE AND
DIFFERENTIATED DISINVESTMENT
SUGGESTED BUSINESS THAT YOU MAY
GET. AN EXACERBATED BY THE
GOVERNMENT'S ECONOMIC CYCLE HAS
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND- WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO LOOK AT A RELEASE
FROM THE EIGHT WE URGE
LEGISLATURE. TO COME CAN BRING
ALMOST FOCAL. WE APPRECIATE AND
THAT THAT MR ADMIN ABOUT THIRD
WHICH YOU CAN USE THIS FOR
INCREASE FROM THE CURRENT MEDIA.
WILL PUT ME. SHOULD THE PROPOSAL
TO EXPAND. FOR CHILDREN
CALIFORNIA CRITICAL. AND LASTLY
SUPPORT NEW JERSEY DOESN'T THE
POUR POINT FROM DOLLARS TO THE
NUMBER OF WHAT THE TEACHER IN
PUBLIC SYSTEM. AND HAS SCHOOL
THE BILL TO CALL SUBSTITUTES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER BRIGHTER. COPYRIGHT TEND
TO BE GO AHEAD- HELLO MY NAME IS
JANET HUNDREDS CAN I'M GONNA
HAVE TO DOCTOR ARAMBULA INCOME
MEMBER. I'M BY CHAIR OF THE
HELLO WHO SUPPORT SERVICES
CONSUMER ALONG. AND I URGE YOU
TO THE ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST- FROM DOCTOR- I
MEAN TO THINK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
. ROTH THROUGH RESTORED. FOR
PUBLIC AGENCIES AUTHORITY
CONSUMER ADVISORY COMMITTEES AND
GOVERNING BOARDS- CONSUMERS NEED
TO BE INVOLVED IN I. HSS POLICY
THEY NEED TO BE INVOLVED IN HI
EXISTENCE OVERSIGHT THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO. ADDING
TO THE- PUBLIC FORTY LOW. WHICH
PASSED MANY YEARS AGO SO I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT. THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COLORS ONE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS REQUEST TO
RESTORE FUNDING FOR THE CONSUMER
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND GOVERNING
BOARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM SIX
ZERO. YES SORRY OF JEOPARDY GEAR
I TRIED TO WORK. THANK YOU FROM
THE BOTTOM OF THE STAIRS AND IT
DIDN'T WORK FORCING HIM TO BE
THE MOST ACCEPTABLE CHAMBER BUT-
PROBABLY DELETED BERKELEY DR-
YOUR- AYE WHAT MARTY OF MOTO AND
WHAT THE WESTERN POWERS CENTER
HAS TO SAY. AND I REPRESENT EACH
DISABILITY THE CALIFORNIA.
PROCESS SORRY. YEAH PLEASE
SPENDING FROM PLANNER IN KERR.
YOU VERY IN THE PROGRAMS.
SUPPORT THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THE BELATED BIRTHDAY THE YOU
FIVE NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ARAMBULA DOCTOR RAINBOWS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE VERY
CHARMING AT THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES HM CALLING
TODAY REGARDING YEAH. WHAT WHAT
TO DO- EXPRESS FEDERAL ATTITUDE
TO THE ADMINISTATION FOR
SEVERAL OF THE PROPOSAL
PARTICULARLY THE ELIMINATION OF
HALF THE BUILDING THE MARKET
CATIONS TO TAILOR THEIR SERVICES
AND EXPANDED ELIGIBILITY FOR
EARLY START SERVICES. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE EMPHASISED ON
PROMOTING WORKFORCE STABILITY
FOR BOTH PROVIDERS AND REGIONAL
CENTERS- WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE
THAT THE WHITE WALKER. CHANGES
IN THIS AREA IS THROUGH SUPPORT
AND- COMMITTEE PASSAGE OF DOCTOR
RIDICULOUS PROPOSAL TO RATE THE
RATE OF STEADY EMPLOYMENT
PATIENTS BY ONE YEAR AS WELL AS
THE PROPOSAL TO THE ROUTE SIXTY
SIX SOME BECAUSE HE. ABOUT EVERY
THREE YEARS- WE DEFINITELY- BUT
OUR SUPPORT FOR STUFF SOME
MEMBER MATT IT'S THE COURSE
AFTER FORMULA TO ADDRESS START
SERVICE FOR. SURE AND THANK YOU
FOR HEARING FOR ALL YOUR SUPPORT
PLAN FOR. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
. THANK YOU WINE ONE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR NUMBER MY NAME IS GINNY
FISHER FROM THE BRIGHT FUTURES
EDUCATION PARTNERSHIP CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSISTANCE THE
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS UNDER
ISSUE TWO FIFTEEN INITIATIVE
SIXTEEN. PRECIADO INCLUSION OF
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND
EXISTING PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS
IN THE GOVERNOR'S NEWLY REVISED.
AND RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO FULLY FUND THE
NINETY TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
BUDGET FAST CHAMPION BY SIMPLY
NUMBER BONTA. INSURE FULL STATE
SUPPORT A CRADLE TO CREATE
ORGANIZATIONS PUT IN WORKING TO
MAKE SURE CHILDREN SIXTEEN. AND
WE WILL TRY TO PASS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU OF WINE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SENATOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AROUND. OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
JD WHITE FORD I AM THE PRESIDENT
OF SPEAKER CALIFORNIA IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES CONSUMER
ALLIANCE AND WE ARE STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION OF MANDATED
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT EVERY
COUNTY FOUR. H. IS THAT FOR THE
SERVICES THAT THEY PROVIDE WE
ALSO SEE OURSELVES AS THE VOICE
OF THE CONSUMER OF AYE AGS
THAT'S REPRESENTING SIX HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND CONSUMERS ARE
IN THE EYE AND SAID THAT PROGRAM
I BROADLY SUPPORT AND P. R. U.
U. D. W. KAPPA AT THE REQUEST
ALREADY MADE HERE TODAY I WANTED
TO DIRECT OUR CONVERSATION TO
ONE THING NOT. ENOUGH IT THE
CURRENT EXAMPLE. FROM OUR JAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA ASK FOR
THE- OF MONDAY. FOR ADVISORY
BACKED THE ORIGINAL AMOUNT
ESTABLISHED WHEN WE WERE FIRST
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE OUT WHICH REDUCE DURING THE
RECESSION AND- TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE. THAT HAS NEVER BEEN
RESTORED WE CANNOT DO OUR JOB
WELL ARE CONSUMERS OF SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND CONSUMERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITHOUT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. SO THAT WE
CAN REACH CONSUMERS GET THEM
INVOLVED AND WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH ALL THE
PARTIES THAT HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH I JUST SENT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. FOR YOUR HELP. I'M NOT
FORWARD TO YOUR SUPPORT THANKS
YOU THANK YOU CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I NO COMMENT THINK YOU
THANK YOU OPERATOR I WILL THAT
AS THE CONCLUSION OF PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR THE DAY I WILL TAKE
A MOMENT TO THANK THE SERGEANTS
THE TAP AS WELL AS TGS FOR
KEEPING US SAFE FOR TRANSMITTING
TODAY AS WELL AS KEEPING. US
CLEAN AND TIDY WE'LL TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENTS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR PRESENTING
TODAY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AS WELL AS THE L. A. O. MOST
IMPORTANTLY I WANT TO THANK BOTH
. TO PREPARE THE END REALLY
ALLOWED US TO HAVE THE NECESSARY-CONVERSATIONS THIS YEAR THE MOST
IMPORTANTLY I WANTED TO THANK
THE PUBLIC- MAKES OUR PROCESS
BETTER AND PRODUCT BETTER. THANK
YOU WE ARE ADJOURNED FOR THE
NIGHT.